Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur Ausgabe 98 von Raumzeit.
Äh ja ich bin immer noch auf Reisen und heute hat mich der Weg nach München geführt.
Und äh vor allem soll mich der Weg aber so ein bisschen in die Vergangenheit führen, in die Geschichte der Raumfahrt, das soll das Thema heute sein,
äh ja da bin ich glaube ich am richtigen Ort nämlich am deutschen Museum und begrüße meinen Gesprächspartner, nämlich Helmut Trischler. Schön.
Hallo, grüß sie, hallo.
Herr Tröschler, Sie sind hier äh in der Museumsleitung des deutschen Museums ähm dabei.
Ähm weiß gar nicht, wie viel Leute sich hier die Arbeit teilen, aber ihr Bereich ist die Forschung, richtig?
Ja wir sind ja ein sogenanntes Forschungsmuseum,
integriertes Forschungsmuseum, das heißt äh wir wir starten eigentlich mit der Forschung und darauf bauen sich alle anderen Funktionen des Museums auf, die Ausstellung, die Sammlung, aber vor allen Dingen auch die Bildungsarbeit und ähm.
Als äh solches sozusagen verantworte ich dann die Forschung, das sind vielleicht äh dazu gehört auch das Archiv, die
des deutschen Museums, äh die die Forschungslaboratorien, denn gerade da im Restaurierungs- und Konservierungswissenschaftlichen Bereich, aber eben auch die wissenschaftstechnik und die Umweltgeschichte. Das ist so meine Profession.
Und ähm.
Das sind so vielleicht hundert Leute äh in meinem Bereich. Also wir wir versuchen da uns schon auch in vielen Kooperationen mit universitärer Forschung, ähm sei es jetzt nun auch in der Wissenschaftskommunikation, sei es in der Bildungsarbeit, aber auch in der ganz konkreten
äh naturwissenschaftlichen Forschung und äh eben Wissenschaftstechnik, Umwelthistorischen Forschung zu tummeln und haben da ähm einen Schwerpunkt.
Der vielleicht auch in der Raumfahrt liegt.
Mhm. Einmal das deutsche Museum bisher wirklich eine ähm eine extrem große Organisation. Hier wird ja äh alles Mögliche abgedeckt. Welchen Teil nimmt denn äh diese Forschung und ist speziell die Raumfahrt ein hier?
Ja, also wir haben eine
große Raumfahrtausstellung, die aktuell nicht äh zu besichtigen ist, weil wir gerade in einer, was wir in den Initiative, also einer grundständigen Sanierung
des deutschen Museums sind als Gebäude zunächst mal Brandschutz und was es da alles so gibt aus Neu zu berücksichtigen ist und da deswegen ist äh derzeit die Hälfte des Museums im Grunde geschlossen für eine Sanierung und äh eine ja auch.
Dann überarbeitung aller Ausstellungen und äh dieser erste Teil wird im Mai nächsten Jahres abgeschlossen sein und dazu gehört eben auch die
Raumfahrtausstellung, die aktuell noch nicht zugänglich ist, aber im Grunde schon wieder aufgebaut ist und wartet, bis die Sanierung abgeschlossen ist, um dann wieder öffnet werden zu können. Das ist eine relativ äh große Ausstellung zusammen eben mit der Luftfahrtausstellung äh so fünf, sechstausend äh Quad,
Meter.
Und die wird dann ab äh Mai nächsten Jahres endlich wieder zu besichtigen sein äh mit auch mit einer Aktualisierung, dass äh die die neuen Themen, die uns darauf kommen sicher noch zu sprechen in der Raumfahrt.
Kommerzialisierung und äh all die Missionen, die in den letzten Jahren gelaufen sind, auch in dieser Ausstellung dann sozusagen.
Aktuell zu sehen sein äh wird.
War die jetzt geschlossen.
Die war jetzt sechs Jahre geschlossen.
Oha, okay.
Sowas dauert, ist eine das sind 70.000 Quadratmeter Ausstellungsfläche äh die da.
Erneuert werden müssen und in einem komplexen Prozess eigentlich eine Operation im offenen Herzen. Wir haben das Museum ja nie geschlossen. Die andere Hälfte.
Bleibt offen mit all den Problemen, die daraus resultieren, aber immerhin, das Haus ist groß genug, sodass äh unsere Besucherinnen und Besucher immer noch was zu sehen haben.
Aber die Raumfahrt Aficionadus, die freuen sich sicherlich darauf, endlich mal wieder unsere Raumfahrt äh besichtigen zu können.
Was hat die Ausstellung denn so abgedeckt bisher.
Ja, schon die, ich sage mal, lange Geschichte der der Raumfahrt,
gerade nicht nur der bundesdeutschen, gerade auch der europäischen Raumfahrt, äh von den Anfängen in den Zwanzigerjahren, als ich äh im Grunde so was wie eine Raumfahrtbegeisterung, gerade auch in Deutschland entwickelte
über die schwierige Geschichte der der Raumfahrt im Nationalsozialismus äh Werner von Braun, Peemünde, ähm.
Das sind äh Themen, die müssen da vorkommen, ja auch mit äh der V zwo Rakete, die da ausgestellt,
äh ist und wieder sein wird äh V eins und so weiter. Ähm.
Bis eben äh nach 9zehnfünfundvierzig das Weltraumrennen äh Space Race zwischen den USA ähm und äh der Sowjetunion, das war ein großer Schwerpunkt und dann vor allen Dingen eben auch die Satelliten äh Mission,
die Kommerzialisierung der Raumfahrt, äh eine große äh Wetterstation Eu.
Mit Wetterstation, sodass wir einfach sehen, dass die Raumfahrt bei uns mitten im Leben angekommen ist und nicht,
irgendwie ein, ich sage mal, ist technisch äh esoterischer Bereich gerade so ist äh der äh der mit
den Alltagserfahrungen äh der Menschen nichts zu tun hat. Das Gegenteil ist ja der Fall und äh also insofern auch den Anwendungsbereich. Der Raumfahrt, den wir aber jetzt sicherlich
werden. Das war man könnte sagen, die Raumfahrt äh so wie sie Bestand ist so in etwa bis 2tausend10 aktuell gewesen
und die die neueren Entwicklungen werden da auch zu sehen sein aber doch auch sozusagen ein Durchgang durch die Geschichte
nicht nur der deutschen Raumfahrt, das deutsche Museum versteht sich gerade nicht als ein nationales Museum, das nur deutsche Technik und Wissenschaft zeigt. Im Gegenteil, so ein aus einer globalen, aus einer planetaren Perspe
gerade in der Raumfahrt ist das ja wichtig, also insofern äh wie gesagt, das äh sowjetisch amerikanische Space Race äh
kommt da genauso vor wie die europäischen Kooperation äh in der Raumfahrtdiesa und äh Galileo und äh.
Weiter zurückreichende Kooperation mit mit schon auch äh sozusagen wirklich wichtigen Exponaten, die
da zu sehen sind die so auch äh der deutschen und europäischen Raumfahrt gewesen sind.
Wird sich denn mit dem,
Umbau auch die Herangehensweise der Ausstellung selbst ändern, also inwiefern passt sich denn das Museum jetzt an die neuen Bedingungen an? Ich meine.
Sozusagen der Kampf um die aufmerksamkeit und das Wissen
der ist ja äh voll entbrannt oder steht vielleicht nicht unbedingt ein Konkurrenz zueinander, aber auf jeden Fall hat natürlich das Internet hier auch eine ganze Menge verändert, was ähm so die Quellen für Informationen betreffen, wie antwortet ein Museum auf.
Auf diese Trends.
Antwortet das deutsche Museum glaube ich ganz offensiv, wie viele andere Museen eben auch. Ähm Stichwort Digitalisierung, ja, dass wir,
so etwas aufbauen äh wie einen digitalen Zwilling des Museums. Wir nennen das deutsches Museum digital, da haben wir sehr früh begonnen und auch sehr
kraftvoll äh begonnen, relativ viel äh auch Ressourcen investiert. Das gehört zu meinem Bereich. Deutsches Museum digital, sodass wir ähm
so viel wie möglich digitalisieren in allen Bereichen archivisches Material, Bibliotheksmaterial, aber insbesondere eben auch dreidimensionale O.
Und die aufeinander bezogen. Nehmen wir mal irgendwie einen Nachlass eines äh Raumfahrtpioniers. Da haben wir dann eben OP.
Wir haben seine Labor äh Bücher oder seine äh sagen wir mal Skizzenbücher und wir haben vielleicht auch seine Bibliothek ja und das
geht in unserer Luft- und Raumfahrtdokumentation ganz besonders. Also insofern äh dieser digitale Zwilling, den bauen wir auf. Ähm
und äh wir haben natürlich äh gerade jetzt in der Pandemie auch noch mal stärker.
Auf äh digitale Ausstellung gesetzt, auf digitale Führung, ähm um eben
ja nicht nur dem Präsenzbesucher und Besuchern etwas zu bieten, sondern im Grunde auch äh eine Global Audience zu bedienen, um mal so zu formulieren,
das das ist äh in wie gesagt äh ein Trend in der Museumsszene. Man könnte sagen, die Pandemie hat das äh beschleunigt. Äh das war schon lange
auf dem Wege oder waren einige Jahre schon auf dem Wege. Die Pandemie hat es beschleunigt äh und insbesondere und eben auch im deutschen Museum.
Das ist eine Reaktion, äh die andere äh würde ich sagen, die äh auch im Zusammenhang mit der Pandemie irgendwie noch mehr Sinn macht als äh je zuvor ist Partizipation.
Wir alle wissen, dass wir,
in einer Wissensgesellschaft äh leben äh und dass wir ähm stärker denn je unsere Besucherinnen und Besucher ja ermächtigen.
Wollen, eine Plattform bieten, einen offenen Raum,
der Partizipation äh sich zu beteiligen am wissenschaftlich äh technischen Dialog äh nicht äh diese Einbahnstraße der Kommunikation weiter fortzuschreiben, die
lange äh Public Understanding of Science auch noch äh um dieses Schlagwort zu gebrauchen in der in der Landschaft vorherrschte, dass da die,
sozusagen autoritär autoritative Stimme der Wissenschaft zur Öffentlichkeit spricht.
Das sind ja Formate, die die die gängig sind, die uns äh auch sozusagen schon schon lange beschäftigen, sondern
Wissenschaft im Dialog äh war, war ja auch eine große Initiative in Deutschland und das aber sozusagen von von der anderen Seite her noch stärker zu denken.
Partizipation wirklich ernst zu nehmen und der Öffentlichkeit äh eine Stimme zu geben. Wenn es drum geht äh Wissenschaft und Technik
mitzugestalten, diese Partizipation und eins der neusten, ich sage mal Kinder, die wir da auch
gezeugt haben und äh und gerade aufbauen, ist ähm wir nennen das Munich äh Center of Science Communication, Science Communication Center on Planet,
die Planetare Gesundheit. Das ist das, was wir ja auch in der Pandemie erleben, die die unauflösliche
Verknüpfung von Umweltgesundheit, Klimawandel et cetera
von menschlicher Gesundheit, ja. Das eine geht ohne das Andere nicht oder das eine ist ohne das andere äh im Grunde sozusagen äh zukünftig weniger denk.
Den je und ähm da haben wir von der Volkswagenstiftung äh eine großzügige Förderung erhalten und wir, das sind dann eben Partner hier im Münchener Raum
die die Wissenschaftskommunikationsforschung an der Universität,
und die planetaren Gesundheitsforscher das ist bei ja ein neues Feld ein, das sich jetzt ähm
Seiten einer Initiative von Lanset seit 215 herausgebildet hat.
Und zwei, ich sage mal, Kommunikations äh äh das ist eben das deutsche Museum und unser Pendant in dem Naturkundebereich Biotopia das äh künftige vergrößerte Architekturkundemuseum.
In München und das Helmholtzzentrum für Gesundheitsforschung äh sind noch weitere Partner, aber das das ist so das
Kernsetting und genau äh da geht's uns auch darum diese sozusagen partizipative Form der Kommunikation dieses neuen Feldes zu bespielen. Also das sind so.
Themen, die uns dort beschäftigen ähm und und und wo wir, glaube ich, schon auch in der internationalen Szene äh Akzente setzen.
In Raumzeit Nummer 86 habe ich hier mit äh Ansgar Grisshake gesprochen, der ähm Naturkundemuseum in Berlin verantwortlich ist für die Meteoritensammlung und äh abgesehen davon, dass er sehr viel Interessantes über Meteoriten äh erzählen äh konnte.
Auch äh schnell klar, dass diese Metoritensammlung und die Arbeit des Museums ja auch Teil des wissenschaftlichen Prozesses ist. Das sind insbesondere die Sammlung und dann eben auch der digitale Zugang äh dazu ja auch verflochten ist mit der wissenschaftlichen Forschung.
Vermute mal Ähnliches findet hier auch statt.
Genau, das nennen wir eben das integrierte Forschungsmuseum, das Naturkundemuseum in Berlin
das deutsche Museum sind zwei unserer sogenannten acht Forschungsmuseumen in Deutschland, also Mitglied der Leibnizgemeinschaft äh dann sozusagen vom Bund und den Ländern gemeinsam äh gefördert und wir sind ein eng verflochtener,
ähm der äh gerade auch ein größeres,
Kram aufgesetzt, hat wir nennen's Aktionsplan, Forschungsmuseum, wo wir viele gemeinsame Aktivitäten fahren, ob wir das jetzt mit Medien
machen wie der FAZ, wo wir jetzt gerade in gemeinsamen äh Wettbewerb haben oder ähm der
Global Summit of Research Museums, da war der Erste vor drei Jahren in Berlin am Naturkundemuseum und äh tatsächlich bin ich äh zufällig äh eben jetzt gerade auch der Organisator des Zweiten äh Global Summits der hätte in zwei Wochen stattfinden sollen, pandemiebedingt haben wir ihn jetzt um ein Jahr
Er findet statt als digitale äh Global Summit äh mit vielleicht 300Museumsdirektorin.
Äh weltweit. Äh das machen wir. Ähm äh neunzehnten, zwanzigsten Oktober.
Und äh als als physische Veranstaltung machen wir's dann äh im Oktober nächsten Jahres. Also da gibt's enge Austauschbeziehungen und das genau diese ja ich nenne das so etwas hochtrabend
sag mal so epstämischer Zirkel, den wir da haben, ja? Die Forschung ist die ist die Ausgangsbasis des Museums und da bauen sich die anderen ähm Produkte und Aktivität,
auf, die Sammlung, die Ausstellung, die Bildungsarbeit und aus der Beschäftigung mit Sammlungen mit Ausstellungen entstehen, dann wieder neue Ideen für neue Forschungs.
Aus denen dann vielleicht wieder eine Ausstellung wird. Also so dies diese diese Verflechtung. Äh das ist das ist das, was wir im integrierten Forschungsmuseum anzielen.
Podcast werden ja auch noch in 500 Jahren gehört, deswegen äh zur Einordnung jetzt äh haben wir gerade Ende September 2021, das heißt äh dieser Summit wird dann in München
Zwanzig zweiundzwanzig dann hoffentlich stattfinden, falls wir uns nicht noch eine weitere Pandemie eintreten. Ich hoffe, das bleibt uns allen erspart. Genauso ist es.
Bevor wir vielleicht in die äh Raumfahrtgeschichte selbst ähm eintreten, würde mich natürlich nochmal interessieren, wie so ihr persönlicher Weg eigentlich da rein äh gewesen ist.
Haben sie eine.
In der Wissenschaft von Anfang an angestrebt oder eher ein Zufalls. War's ein Zufallsbund? Es gibt ja solche und solche.
Zufeige äh vielleicht Gericht oder Zufall, Kontingenz nennt man das. Also ähm ich ich bin Historiker, allgemein Historiker eigentlich von meiner Ausbildung her.
Und und zufällig in in das Thema Technik und und Wissenschaftsgeschichte gekommen über über meine Dissertation, die über technische Angestellte war und dann vor allen Dingen über mein zweites Buch äh Habilitation in Deutschland
wo es um die Luft und Raumfahrtforschung ging, also eine Geschichte der Luft- und Raumfahrtforschung als ich habe das genannt, so politische Wissenschaft,
politisierte Wissenschaft, früh äh politisierte Wissenschaft so von äh also in der Luftfahrtforschung um die Entstehung um 1900 herum äh bis in die 197er Jahre und äh das für die Luftfahrt und Raumfahrtforschung habe ich mir angeguckt.
Wie sich also diese politisierte und politische Wissenschaft da jetzt in in Deutschland entwickelt hat
und und seither bin ich sozusagen in diesem Feld ähm äh der Wissenschafts- und Technikgeschichte und macht das professionell und insbesondere seit ich dann also äh nicht nur an der Universität tätig bin, sondern eben auch im deutschen Museum so eine.
Doppelte ähm.
Aufgabe ähm hier die Forschung zu verantworten und dann eine Professur jetzt in dem Fall an der an der Universität in München für Wissenschaft und Technikgeschichte und Umweltgeschichte zu haben.
Dann habe ich noch ein Zentrum für Umweltforschung. Äh nennt sich Rachel Carsten Center for Invement zur Seite.
Im Grunde, was äh eine Kooperation der der Universität München und des deutschen Museums ist so seit zwölf Jahren, haben wir so ein so eine Thinktank, so eine internationales mhm ja Kolleg äh für um
geisteswissenschaftliche Umweltforschung. Wir haben immer so etwa 30 äh Wissenschaftler und Wissenschaftler aus der ganzen Welt hier in München, die mit uns gemeinsam über Umweltfragen nachdenken
und das ist das sind so Fragen, äh die mich ganz besonders beschäftigen und dazu kommt natürlich oder das hat zur Raumfahrt einen Bezug. Na ja und seither wie gesagt.
Bin ich der der Raumfahrt irgendwie auch verbunden geblieben war, lange Zeit auch in der in der ESA, der European Space Agency in einem History-Panel.
Äh so war auch so was gibt's äh in der Isar, die sozusagen ihre eigene Geschichte mit
pflegen, aber das nicht aus dem Haus heraus machen, sondern sozusagen einen internationalen Beirat haben äh und da habe ich viele Interviews auch geführt mit Raumfahrtpionieren für die Isar.
Und so äh bin ich der Raumfahrt verbunden.
Mhm.
Also auf der einen Seite ein Quereinsteiger, aber mittlerweile kann man das glaube ich nicht mehr behaupten. Irgendwann sitzt man ja dann äh voll drin. Mir geht's nicht sehr viel anders hier in diesem Podcast.
Ja, also ich wollte heute mal ein wenig äh genauer beleuchten, wie sich denn das eigentlich alles
die Raumfahrt hat, wir haben's ja jetzt auch schon angedeutet durch die Ausstellung, die im Prinzip versucht so einen ähnlichen Weg auch nachzuzeichnen.
Einen äh aus deutscher Perspektiv
heraus doch sehr verschlungenen Pfad genommen und äh war vor allem halt äh zu Beginn auch stark Kriegs getrieben, weil eben einfach die entscheidenden Erfindungen, die Raumfahrt überhaupt erst ermöglicht
haben eben genau in diese dreißiger und vierziger Jahre hineingefallen sind, wo der Mensch äh mit seiner,
Technikkunst auf einmal in der Lage war diese
einerseits das mathematische äh äh Wissen zu haben und äh auch eine Vorstellung von von Raum und natürlich durch Einstein auch die passenden wissenschaftlichen Theorien äh auf einmal am Start waren, die.
Ja ist überhaupt erst ermöglicht haben, dass man über so etwas nachdenken kann. Wenn man jetzt so ähm das.
Also mein Ziel ist ja so ein bisschen mal äh eine europäische Perspektive vor allem aufzumachen, wie sich das die Raumfahrt bei uns entwickelt hat, aber.
Wie weit muss man dann sozusagen zurückblicken, um wirklich so einen Urmoment zu erfühlen.
Ja äh wenn wir von der europäischen Raumfahrt äh Kultur sprechen, äh dann ist das sicher ein gut gesetzter Begriff.
Der ähm um die Jahrhundertwende anzusetzen ist oder dessen Wurzeln in der um die Jahrhundert äh Wende anzusetzen sind und da eine
kleine Korrektur. Ich glaube, die die Anfänge der Raumfahrt sind zunächst mal schon ziviler Natur und sie werden dann sozusagen relativ rasch, sie haben's erwähnt. Wir kommen gleich darauf, militärisch Usub,
ja aber die die Raumfahrtbegeisterung kommt aus einer ähm Gerichte teilt um die Jahrhundertwende, um die Wende vom 19 zum 2 Jahrhundert. Da finden wir relativ viele Visionen Uto
ähm überall in Europa äh Schildwerden ist ein Beispiel, aber viele viele andere ähm und ähm.
Aus dieser Zukunftsorientierung heraus ent,
gerade in den 20erjahren und hier schon speziell in Deutschland eine besondere äh besondere Raumfahrtbegeisterung ein.
Ein amerikanischer Kollege hat das mal aus Misonia Institution hat das mal Space Flight fad in Europe genannt, ja? Also sozusagen dies diese Begeisterung äh in den 20erjahren und wir alle kennen den Film Frau im Mond äh.
Und äh von Fritz Lang äh und und viele andere Formate, die gerade in der Weimarer Republik äh äh in Deutschland Obliquitär waren, dass der beginnende Kino ähm.
Und äh die Tageszeitung bespielt ein großes Interesse der Öffentlichkeit für die Zukunft und insbesondere für die äh Raumfahrt äh Zukunft, die sich da entwickelt hat. Ähm und ähm.
Ja und dann da begegnen uns diese Figuren, wie war eine von Braun und andere.
Zunächst mal, ja, als als junge begeisterte Ingenieure, die da was aufbauen, die basteln und sich ihren Raketenflugplatz bauen. Ähm.
Und dann aber äh werden sie sozusagen entdeckt.
Von den Militärs, ja. Wir wir sind jetzt hier ein Ende der zwanziger Jahre als so was wie eine geheime Wiederaufrüstung in Deutschland stattfindet. Sie will an den alliierten Kontrollkontrollen, die so was verbieten, vorbei.
Äh dass Heeres Waffenamt äh entdeckt das und bemächtigt sich also dieser jungen Raumfahrt,
und spannt die in ihre Dienste ein und die spannt sie natürlich insbesondere dann ihre äh Dienste ein nach 1933, als das nicht mehr in nur im Geheimen stattfindet, sondern dann sozusagen offen gelegt wird.
Und dann wird äh wird Werner von Braun äh hier ähm ganz offensiv umarmt äh von den Militärs und es werden ihm und seinen Teams ermöglich.
Wie sie nirgendswo äh sonst äh geboten werden, auch international und dann kommt es eben zum Aufbau.
Von Peemünde, also dieser damals Heeresversuchsanstalt. Das äh ist einer der Rüstungs.
Im Nationalsozialismus gewesen,
waren häufig konkurrierend unterwegs, gab Heres Versuchsanstalt Ost, das ist Peemünde und eine Westfrau, da war die Luftwaffe, ja und jetzt hier und das und die Luftwaffe konkurriert und die hatten jeden äh ihr ihre äh streng voneinander abgeschotteten Technik.
Ein Pänemünde. Na ja, jedenfalls wenn er vom Braunbaute dann seinen Komplex auf.
Und äh daraus äh wurde dann eben äh die V zwo, ja, weil die A vier äh,
zunächst mal und dann eben als Vergeltungswaffe fort äh zwo genannt. Das ist der Beginn, wenn man so will jetzt,
der Raumfahrt äh international und die V zwo ist sicherlich einer der äh bis dahin ohnehin äh größten Rüstungskomplexe, die es weltweit gegeben hat. Wir schätzen das etwa äh 2 Milliarden.
Reichsmark verschlungen hat.
Ein riesiger, ein riesiger Technikkomplex mit 10.000 Ingenieuren, äh die da und Wissenschaftler, die da beschäftigt waren.
Und sehr vielen Songsarbeitern, die ihr Leben gelassen haben beim Bau der V zwei. Das wissen wir heute auch und das gilt's immer mitzudenken und zusammenzudenken und das äh Werner von äh Braun das wusste, äh mit wem er sich da eingelassen hat,
äh äh sozusagen was äh seine Forschung und vor allen Dingen seine Entwicklungsarbeiten für Konsequenzen hatten. Das wissen wir heute auch.
Wie würden Sie diesen Menschen charakterisieren? Ich meine, am Anfang über eine Begeisterung, die jetzt noch äh entkoppelt war, äh.
Zwanziger Jahren, von dem was danach äh kam, dann wurde er halt entdeckt, wurde irgendwie tja weiß ich nicht rekrutiert oder vielleicht auch einfach mit den Möglichkeit,
sich so seinen eigenen persönlichen Traum zu erfüllen ohne jetzt diese Konsequenzen zu sehen. Gibt ja auch dieses äh Zitat so.
Ja was ist wo die Raketen wieder runterkommen? So ja das ist nicht mal Department, das ist irgendwie nicht da habe ich nicht drüber nachzudenken
Ist ja auch so ein bisschen so ein.
So eine Art Sünden äh Fall, so was was habe ich für eine Verantwortung für mein eigenes äh Handeln? Wie bewerten die Historiker seine Rolle?
Ja äh es gibt hier eine ganz vorzügliche Biografie äh eines amerikanischen Kollegen Michael Nohfeld, Michael Neufeld äh äh
Kurator für Raumfahrt ein ähm Nationalmuseum äh Air and Space Museum in in den USA, der eine 600 Seiten dicke Biografie
Das ist das autorisierte, ich sage mal äh nicht autorisierte, aber das wichtigste Werk äh gewesen und er nennt äh das äh Dreamer of Space, aber dann eben auch äh das gegen äh das Gegenbild und ich glaube, beides ist richtig. Also Werner von Braun war sicherlich überzeugt davon, dass ähm äh,
ist eine sozusagen zivile Zukunft äh der Raumfahrt geben wird und dass man äh vor allen Dingen.
Er wollte ja zum Mars zunächst mal die Mondlandung war für ihn. Dann irgendwie ja kam er eben dazu äh und und und musste sozusagen diesen Umweg gehen, aber eigentlich wollte er zur Maus.
Und und das hat ihnen frühzeitig wie wie die ganze Literatur, die Zukunftsliteratur, die äh mit der er groß geworden ist, beschäftigt
und und das das war sicherlich sein Antrieb ja aber er wir kennen in Deutschland ähm oder haben mittlerweile
glaube ich gerade im im im Bereich jetzt auch der Wissenschafts- und Technikgeschichte, eine Vielzahl von von äh ähnlich gelagerten äh,
ähm sozusagen in den Blick genommen und da war eben diese äh.
Können von einer äh wechselseitigen Ressourcenmobilisierung reden. Das äh NS-Regime brauchte die Ingenieure, es brauchte die, die die Wissenschaftler und die Wissenschaftler profit.
Davon, ja, ihre ihre ähm ihre Forschung konnten sie ausweiten, sie konnten neue Disziplinen.
Begründen, sie sie bekamen Möglichkeiten.
Der technischen und wissenschaftlichen Entfaltung an die Hand, die natürlich großartig waren, die bestechend sind, ja? Nicht bestechi, aber bestechend sind und und viele äh Naturwissenschaftlerinnen und Naturwissenschaftler und Ingenieure haben das eben genutz.
Ist ja auch heute nicht anders.
Das ist heute nicht anders. Die Politisierung von Wissenschaft und Technik ist heute genauso da und die war im Kalten Krieg. Äh ebenso da. Aber es macht natürlich schon einen Unterschied
man dann mit äh mit zieht, ja, wie, wie, wie, wie
zehntausende von Zwangsarbeiter und Zwangsarbeiter da ums Leben kommen oder nicht. Also von daher ist die Verantwortung äh es frage schon eine wichtige und und die moralische Frage ein wichtiger, aber wir können das erklären aus dieser ja aus aus diesem Ressourcenüberfluss äh der der
grade in den Bereichen. Sie müssen sich vorstellen, im in der Weimarer Weimarer Republik, also bis äh äh war waren Raketen verboten
äh oder oder oder es war noch gar nicht erfasst, aber die die also Motoren, man konnte ja eigentlich keine Motoren äh größeren äh Maßstabs äh äh grade in der Luftfahrt insbesondere entwickeln und dann kommt
plötzlich ein Regime und überhäuft einen mit Möglichkeiten, ja und das ist natürlich verführerisch und ähm und wurde genutz.
So müssen wir das auch bei Wanne von Braun sehen ähm und und er war sicherlich ein genialer äh Macher, äh nicht nur Finder und auch kreative Ingenieur, sondern auch Organisator
und diesen riesigen Komplex ja ein wissenschaftlich-technisch akademischen Komplex hat er da in Peemünde aufgebaut.
Geleitet ja und und mit seiner charismatischen Führungspersönlichkeit äh zusammengehalten.
All der äh wir nennen es polygratischen äh.
Probleme im im nationalsozialismus, wo jeder gegen jeden im politischen äh Raum gibt, gekämpft hat, ja und um Ressourcen. Er hat das zusammengehalten.
Das prägte ihn auch und da kommen wir jetzt, wenn man so will, äh schon äh auch in die Fünfziger, Sechziger in das Apollo-Programm hinein. Ähm diese Vorstellung.
Ich habe hier ein wissenschaftlich technischen Komplex äh der zusammengehalten wird durch mich der integriert ist,
der seine Stärke daraus bezieht, dass alles unter einem Dach zu passieren hat, ja und dass ich äh alles kontrollieren kann, dass ähm.
Dann als er nach 1945 in den USA tätig wird und äh darauf kommen wir jetzt vielleicht zu sprechen.
Genau, also man muss sagen halt nach der Niederlage Deutschlands äh oder einfach ja der Kapitulation des Nazi-Regimes.
Das halt immer so ist ähm.
Das Land ist besiegt, aber die äh besten und diejenigen, die äh wirklich bis äh bis dahin das System auch am,
am Laufen gehalten haben, insbesondere in solchen technischen Bereichen sind natürlich von großem Interesse und die USA haben ihn halt ein Angebot gemacht, was er so nicht ablehnen äh konnte oder wollte und äh haben einfach gesagt, mach doch einfach das,
verwirkliche doch deine Träume bei uns und dann ist er eben zur NASA gewechselt oder war sozusagen Teil der des der Geburt der NASA.
Genau, zunächst zu Army. Ähm wir nennen das intellektuelle Reparation.
Dies ist äh dass die dass die Alliierten und nicht nur die USA genauso die Sowjets und genauso äh Großbritannien und Frankreich der deutschen Spezialisten äh Ingenieure äh Experten habhaftig werden wollten.
Und zwar in der Konstellation, in der sich der kalte Krieg formierte, ja? Und äh und jeder für sich da Vorteile verschaffen wollte. Und schon noch während des Krieges gab es ähm.
Teams, äh die äh sozusagen ausspäten und die Aufgabe hatten, wen gibt's denn da in Deutschland, der die an diesen Wunderwaffen und so weiter abbau
äh sprich an an äh Innovation, Technologien, die wir brauchen können für die Zeit nach dem
Krieg und vor allen Dingen für die sich abzeichnende Verlängerung in in den kalten Krieg hinein und das waren äh das waren Spezialistenteams, Wissenschaftlerteams, die sozusagen vorrückend mit der Front äh nach Deutschland kamen und dann
die Experten Befragten Werner von Braun äh genauso befragt wie die wie die äh jenigen die in der
Kernwaffenforschung tätig waren, die in der Mikroelekt äh in der Elektronik äh äh sich äh neue,
Waffensysteme überlegt hatten in Deutschland et cetera und sie wurden sowohl jetzt äh der Teams harbhaftig als auch der,
der Baupläne et cetera, die da herrschten, äh die da vorhanden waren. Und und so äh wurde auch noch von Braun befragt und da merkt man, ja okay, das ist äh die den brauchen wir äh für den Bau von äh,
äh und insbesondere dann im Zusammenhang ähm mit der Atombombe für nukleare Trägerwaffen.
Das ist das, was Wanne von Braun dann zunächst mal äh machte er und und seine Penemünder. Er nahm einfach möglichst viele seiner Vertrauten mit und dieses Team Penemünde war dann eben,
zuerst meinen äh in Hansviel Alabama und baute für äh für die US US Armee äh nukleare Raketen.
Als Trägerraketen. Und äh erst später kam äh als dann sozusagen das Apollo-Programm ins Laufen kam nach dem Sputnik-Shop,
Schock äh parallel dazu bediente er schon äh er war einfach auch eine öffentliche Person.
Die es verstanden mit den Medien zu spielen und sozusagen seine Vision der Mauslandung dann weiter zu
stricken sozusagen in den USA und der wurde sozusagen zu einem öffentlichen Wissenschaftler, öffentlichen Ingenieur, der äh medial sehr präsent war.
Und äh und da sich sozusagen dann platzierte und als es dann für ähm äh ja äh zu zu dem großen.
Kenne die lancierten äh sozusagen Programm äh äh Programm kam, wenn man so will. Da war er schon in Stellung, konnte konnte konnte sich äh,
empfehlen dafür, dass er derjenige ist, der ein solches großes Programm stemmen kann.
Wie war denn da die Perspektive der Amerikaner auf seine Person? Ich meine er war ja dann sozusagen jahrelang wurde ihnen halt immer erzählt ja die Deutschen, das sind so die ganz äh bösen Menschen. Und dann holen wir uns doch einfach mal die und dann sind das unsere Popstars.
Ja äh tatsächlich äh haben die äh amerikanischen Medien, dass ähm äh relativ.
Eindeut.
Weil da war nicht mehr viel von NS-Vergangenheit, sondern da war er war mittlerweile Amerikaner geworden, hatte die US-amerikanische Staatsbürgerschaft. Wie so viele andere äh USA sind ja doch ein Meting
und dann äh war er eben im amerikanischen Staatsbürger und dessen die NS-Vergangenheit war da weit weg oder wurde eigentlich kaum bedient, sondern eigentlich seine Vision.
Seine Zukunftsvision, die so äh plakativ waren und in diesen amerikanischen Technikmagazinen et cetera,
blumig und farbig in der im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes ausgemalt worden sind. Und der war ein genialer äh Wissenschaftskommunikator und ähm Disney äh bediente sich Disney und und vieler anderer Medien und wurde so so ein früher.
Da kann man sagen jetzt der der Wissenschaft und und darauf sprang die Medien an.
Weil er einfach auch zum amerikanischen Selbstverständnis und dem amerikanischen Traum einfach äh passte, so der Sky ist the limit und in dem Fall noch nicht mal mehr der Himmel.
Wie wurde das jetzt aus was wurde sozusagen in dieser Zeit aus Europa? Weil das war ja im Prinzip,
auch äh diese.
Dieser äh Intellektuellen äh Ressourcen und natürlich auch anderer äh Ressourcen so im in der Nachkriegszeit, da war natürlich Europa vor allem erst mal damit beschäftigt, überhaupt erst mal wieder auf die Beine zu kommen. Das sollte ja nochmal so
zehn, 15 Jahre dauern, bis der europäische Motor auch wirtschaftlich insgesamt wieder ähm zum Laufen kam.
Welches Dasein hat dann die Raumfahrt dort überhaupt noch befristet? Was war denn noch übrig?
Sie sprechen ein Feld an, das mich selber auch immer in meinen Arbeiten sehr beschäftigt. Das ist so die Ausbildung. Ich sage mal des Integrierten, wissenschaftlichen Europas, wissenschaftlich technischen Europas. Ich bin ja der Meinung, dass Europa ähm
den
zwar auch eine politische Konstruktion, ist auch eine wirtschaftliche Konstruktion ist, aber vor allen Dingen auch zusammengehalten wurde und wird durch äh wissenschaftlich-technische Kooperation, Integration. Ich spreche ja von der,
äh hinten Integration, die verdeckte Integration Europas, die aus dieser Zirkulation und Kooperation von Wissenschaft und Technik heraus entstanden ist und äh einer der Motoren ist da die Raumfahrt.
Frühjahrssitzen andere Bereiche ein. Äh Sie wissen, äh wir das ist ähm sagen wir mal, dass das das Rolemodel, wie sagt man das, Vorbildmodell für auch für die da ein Raumfahrtkooperation ist, die europäische Zusammenarbeit im Bereich der Teilchenphysik.
Physik äh das Zerren, das ähm äh also das große europäische ähm Teilchen, Forschungs- und ähm.
Ja Materialforschungs äh zentrum äh in der Nähe von Genf ähm das 1954 gegründet wurde, ja als sozusagen Gegenstück Europas, gegen die großen äh Forschungszentren
in den USA und wo Europa sich platziert ja und so sagt er auch
Wir wollen ein friedliches Europa schaffen, durch Zusammenarbeit der wissenschaftlich-technischen Eliten in Europa auf diesen Zukunftsfeldern ja und da war das äh das Zaun eben
das rollte ja den Lerch, Hardon Cola hat und wo äh
jüngste ja erst wieder äh sozusagen dunkle Materie und so weiter im im Vordergrund stehen. Also nach wie vor einer der der der großen äh Motoren der europäischen äh Zusammenarbeit das hatten auch die Begründer der
Idee der europäischen Raumfahrt im Auge. Die kamen nämlich.
Aus diesem Bereich heraus. Äh George Messi und äh Pierre Oger und wie sie hießen ähm und die dachten sich so was braucht man für die Raumfahrt auch.
Nach dem Sputnik-Shop, als als man merkte, hoppla, diese,
polarisierte, wissenschaftlich technische und aber auch politisch polarisierte Welt, teilt sich, wenn man jetzt so will, ähm.
Äh die Filetstückchen auf, da sind die Sowjets und da sind die äh USA und Europa spielt da keine Rolle mehr. Wird da ähm eigentlich.
Außen vorgehalten und ähm das das soll geändert werden und da gab's eben erste.
Initiativen um 1960 herum sozusagen im Nachgang des Sputnik-Schocks äh.
War siebenundfuffzig, ne?
Puddingweihende 7fünfzig ähund dann formierten sich solche Ideen. Ja also wenn die Amerikaner jetzt so äh äh mit mit Apollo ähm.
Reagieren, wenn die Sowjets äh einen solchen mächtigen Komplex aufbauen. Wo ist da Europa? Äh die technologische Lücke, die da.
Äh zwischen äh zwischen diesen beiden Großmächten, aber insbesondere auch den USA und Europa. Wie kann sich Europa da platzieren und in diese Aufbruchstimmung Europas, Anfang der sechziger Jahre, hinein äh eben kommen auch die ersten Bemühungen
Europa im Bereich der Raumfahrt wieder auf die Landkarte zu bringen.
Und und dann äh sind äh einige dieser ja frühen Vordenker äh sozusagen an die Politik herangetreten. Großbritannien Frankreich,
eben auch Deutschland äh die aus zu Beginn der sechziger Jahre die Bundesrepublik dann doch auch schon wieder mächtiger äh Akteur ist, ähm um die die Ressourcen zu bündeln und zu sagen.
Schafft man das jeweils nicht
wie kommen wir denn da zusammen? Wie können wir ein europäisches Gegenprodukt, wenn man so will, jetzt zu äh zu Apollo oder zu den äh amerikanischen,
sowjetischen Trägerraketen aufbauen oder auch und auch zu Weltraumforschung aufbauen und dann kommt es eben
1962 zur Gründung der European Lounge Development Organisation, also der Elton zum Aufbau.
Trägerraketen und dem äh ja Gegenstück oder äh dem Kompliment der komplementären Organisation, Organisation European Space Research Organisation, wo sich die Weltraum
Wissenschaftler äh äh zusammenfinden und diese beiden Organisationen arbeiten dann sozusagen separat oder parallel
ähm haben natürlich was miteinander zu tun, weil die Satelliten, die sich die Weltraumwissenschaftler ausdenken, die sollen dann eben mit den Trägerraketen
geflogen werden, die die European Lounge Eveliment Organisation baut. Und ähm vielleicht das jetzt mal sozusagen als.
Zwischenfazit, diese Phase 1962, 63, 64 wird dann zu einer schwierigen Geburt.
Europäische Raumfahrt äh Kooperation, was einfach auch nochmal hindeutet auf,
Probleme, die äh Europa zu diesem Zeitpunkt eben hatte und ich glaube, die Lernprozesse.
Bedeutet Kooperation, äh wie kann man äh transnationale Zusammenarbeit in einem so komplexen Feld wie Raumfahrt aufsetzen, die Lernprozesse, die hier gegangen werden
mussten. Die waren schmerzlich, die waren schmerzlich für die Ingenieure und Naturwissenschaftler. Die waren aber auch schmerzlich für den europäischen Steuerzahler, der sehr viel Geld hier sozusagen hinblättern musste, um äh
Lernprozesse äh erfolgreich zu gestalten.
Das heißt, man hat quasi erstmal ähm also mein meine ich habe ich habe die fünfzehn Jahre jetzt mal so salopp daher gesagt. Das war so ein bisschen meine Erwartung und
tatsächlich passt es ja dann auch ganz gut so Anfang der sechziger Jahre. Das Apolloprogramm, glaube ich, 1undsechzig äh los, dann,
dem sich die USA quasi wieder berappelt hat nach eben diesem Schock, also der letzten Endes nur von den Piepen eines einzigen Satelliten ausgelöst wurde.
Rolle der Russen ist natürlich jetzt hier auch noch mal äh sehr, sehr relevant, die ja einen eigenständigen Weg geschafft haben, die aus ihrer eigenen äh Wissenschaft und und Technikentwicklung herausgeschafft haben, sich dort,
platzieren oder.
Die hatten ja auch die deutschen Ingenieure äh sich sozusagen geholt.
Ach so, die andere Hälfte so.
Die andere Hälfte, die da noch geblieben sind, die sind in einer Nacht im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes Nacht-und-Nebel-Aktionen äh,
Operation hieß die wann war das August 1946? Sind all die, die also in der in der Ostzone, in der.
Äh
Besatzungstour, sowjetischen Besatzungszone verblieben sind. Äh die Experten äh und das waren viele, äh die die ähm sind zuerst in sogenannten äh Konstruktionsbüros ähm versammelt worden. Der der Sowjets und äh dann sind die.
Wahrsten Sinne des Wortes besoffen gemacht worden. Äh da gab's eine große Feier und äh die Pläne lagen sozusagen äh aufm Tisch und dann sind die äh abgezogen worden äh.
Aber Peenemünde lag doch auch im Osten, also.
Im Osten, aber äh Werner von Braun und andere haben sich vorher wie viele andere in den Westen geflüchtet in die amerikanische Besatzungszone
weil sie wussten, okay wir wollen es nicht in die Hände der Sowjets
geraten, aber viele andere Spezialisten blieben eben außen. Und diese wurden also zwotausend äh neunzehnhundertsechsundvierzig ähm äh nach Russland äh in die Sowjetunion ans Schwarze Meer äh ähm verschifft ähm und äh hatten da einige Jahre zur
und äh das waren auch eben Triebwerkspezialisten, das waren Raketenspezialisten. Insofern gab's auch da ein Technologietransfer sozusagen von äh NS Technik,
in sowjetische Technik, äh die Sowjets haben das dann bald selbst übernommen. Äh aber äh also insofern.
So eine Infusion gab's schon, ja.
Das ist ein sehr schöner äh Begriff hier an der Stelle. Äh den gab es auch.
Mhm. Diese Wissenschafts äh Kooperation.
Über das Zerren und so. Ich meine, das sah, wenn man heute so auf Europa blickt, dann ist es immer einfach zu sagen, so ah ja, Europa wird sich nicht einig und ähm.
Kriegen diese vielen Sprachen und Kulturen kriegen wir irgendwie dann doch immer nicht überwunden und auch in der Pandemie haben wir gesehen, wie sich wie sich die Problematik schnell so nationalisiert hat, weil es einfach keine gemeinsame.
Sprache, in dem Sinne gibt. Es gibt keine.
Gemeinsamen europäischen, politischen Themen, die in Europa, es läuft immer in jedem Land nach einem anderen Zyklus mit einer anderen Gewichtung, mit einem anderen Hintergrund, mit einer anderen Geschichte, einer anderen Bedeutung und es ist äh manchmal erscheint es einem.
Schwierig äh sich Europa als ein ganzes ähm wirklich zu denken. Auf der anderen Seite ist ja eben diese Integration Europas.
An so vielen Stellen auch schon wiederum
so perfekt, dass sie manchmal erst gesehen wird, wenn sie wegfällt, wie wir das jetzt zum Beispiel beim Brexit äh sehen jetzt, wo gerade äh Großbritannien so ein bisschen seine Einzelteile äh zerfällt, weil ihnen einfach ja etwas verloren gegangen ist, was sie vielleicht so
als Gesellschaft gar nicht mehr gesehen haben. Und die Wissenschaft scheint ja hier äh.
Neben der Wirtschaft nimmt eine wichtige Rolle zu spielen. Natürlich ist auch Wissenschaft und Wirtschaft eng miteinander äh verbunden. CERN haben wir als Beispiel schon genannt. Diese Bewegung hin.
Wissenschaft für Raumfahrt zu machen, die dann letztlich zu Eldo und Eso geführt hat
Wer war da die Triebfeder? Waren das dann die Franzosen? Es fehlen schon zwei französische Namen ähm war das eine Initiative der Deutschen. Wie kam wie kam es überhaupt dazu, dass man sich.
Äh wieder treffen wollen.
Ja Sie haben's gut beschrieben. Äh zunächst mal die Triebkräfte, die Katalysatorenwahlen, die Naturwissenschaftler und Ingenieure, ja, die tatsächlich eine Vision hatten
Europa auf die Landkarte hier zu setzen und äh auch den Friedensprozess voranzutreiben, in dem äh Europa,
jenseits der US-amerikanischen und sowjetischen,
Bildung sozusagen einen einen dritten Komplex, der auf zivile Technik setzt ähm aufbauen. Das das waren deren aus der Erfahrung.
Des Zweiten Weltkriegs heraus. Das waren die war die Motivation und dann ähm sind äh diese.
Ja äh Wissenschaftler an die Politik herangetreten und dann kam's eben zu sozusagen zu einer Art äh Europäisierung unter nationalen Vorzeichen, äh Interessenvorzeichen.
Frankreich und Großbritannien waren sicher die Treiber da und zwar aus aus einer politischen Logik heraus, die da hieß okay wir haben äh hier äh in in äh Raketenprogramme investiert und wir sehen,
Das geht eigentlich über unsere Kräfte hinaus. Jetzt holen wir doch die anderen äh mit ins Boot und sozusagen
europäisieren unsere Programme. Da gab's äh in Großbritannien ein sagen wir mal fehlgeschlagenes, ein schlecht geplantes Programm. Eine Trägerrakete für.
Äh kaum Waffen zu bauen, Bluestreet History äh und das war die erste und die wurde dann, also sozusagen eine Trägerrakete für äh äh Atomspringköpfe, die wurde dann,
zivilisiert äh und äh und den und diesem sich formierenden europäischen Konsortium als erste Stufe angeboten. Ja, also die äh äh britische Regierung
wollte im Grunde Kapital aus einem verfehlten Rüstungsprojekt äh schlagen und sagen, okay jetzt nehmen wir da noch ein bisschen Geld ein. Haben wir so viel da investiert und das das wird jetzt ein zu einer zivilen ähm zum zivilen Projekt äh umdefiniert und das bieten wir Europa an.
Sollen die Deutschen bezahlen und sollen die Franzosen bezahlen.
Das Gleiche war in Frankreich, das hieß äh Coralie. Das war dann auch ein äh äh Projekt ähm zunächst mal das Unterrüstungsvorzeichen aufgesetzt worden ist und der die Franzosen boten, das heißt zweite Stufe an.
Brauchten sie noch äh Deutschland falls äh mit Zahlen der starker, potenter Partner und weitere Partner, aber insbesondere Deutschland und die Deutschen, denen wurde dann angeboten, die dritte Stufe zu bauen.
Ja und dann ergaben sich also französische und äh britische ähm Politiker, insbesondere der britische Verteidigungsmiss. Wenn es,
Peter Fonicraft äh Anfang 196zwo oder im Jahr 19zwo6und, diesem Scharnierjahr, der Ausbildung des äh Vereinten Europas in der Raumfahrt in Bonn die Klinke in die Hand und äh F
massive äh Politik für diese Idee einer europäischen äh integrierten Raumfahrt ähm
und äh Deutschland war da zunächst mal nicht entscheidungsfähig. Erstens Mal gab's es gab äh zu dem Zeitpunkt
noch keine verrüchtige Zuständigkeit für die Raumfahrt, das äh äh ähm Vorläufer des heutigen äh also Bundesforschungsministeriums wurde erst geboren, man war nicht sprechfähig
war nicht sprechfähig, dann äh gingen also,
die äh Briten um Franzosen ging zum Bundeskanzler, ging zum Wirtschaftsminister, ging zum Verteidigungsminister, ging zum Innenminister und überall bekam sie unterschiedliche Auskünfte. Je äh je nach Aerosurinteresse,
dann ja da sind wir interessiert oder sind wir weniger interessiert und es war dann tatsächlich.
Ardenau, der dann Machtwort sprechen musste und sagt, okay, jetzt brauchen wir eine abgestimmte wir
Deutschen sind doch eigentlich die die Triebfedern für reden immer davon von der Integration Europas und jetzt kommen hier mal die diese äh immer äh eher äh schwierigen Partner.
Auf uns zu und wollen.
Uns damit ins Boot nehmen äh dann müssen wir doch da sozusagen äh handlungsfähig sein ähm und da äh ließen sich dann also auch die deutschen Experten
zunächst mal sehr sehr skep
waren, weil sie sahen, dass diese Blues Streak eigentlich sich nicht eignet für eine äh europäische Trägerrakete, dass man das ganz anders aufsetzen müsste und dass wenn,
dieser Basis.
Trägerrakete gebaut werden würde, dass die zu dem Zeitpunkt, als sie dann vielleicht einsatzreif sein würde, längst überholt sein würde, ja? Also die Deutschen wollten im Grunde
technologisch in die Zukunft springen und das überwinden, was äh ihnen die Franzosen und ähm.
Engländer anboten, aber das war eben der Deal. Ja, man bekam nur diesen Deal und ähm immerhin bekam er die Aufgabe, was Neues zu bauen, die dritte Stufe, die es nicht gab
Äh und und wo man sozusagen fortgeschrittene Technologien zum Einsatz
bringen konnte und das war dann schon auch wiederum äh verführerisch oder war war war äh spannend
und dann gab's also lange Gespräche mit den deutschen Experten, die sich dann also davon überzeugen ließen. Ja, wenn wir dann also diese dritte Stufe schon äh sozusagen hochenergetisch ansetzen, dann machen wir das.
Äh wollen aber sozusagen gewahrt wissen, äh dass wir äh möglichst äh in der in der zweiten Phase dann in die Zukunft.
Hineinspringen. Also ein sehr komplexer Deal und ähm
wurde für die Niederländer und die Belgier und die Italiener noch mit ins Boot geholt, um den Satelliten oben drauf zu setzen und die die Bodenkontrolle äh zu verantworten und.
Australien äh sollte da hast du sozusagen die Test äh äh Range äh zur Verfügung stellen den Woomerer, also sozusagen eben als britische.
Britisches Gebiet sozusagen, da gab's noch nicht äh äh in Französisch-Guyana als den europäischen Weltraumbahnhof, sondern das war Woomer in in Australien. Also,
ehemaligen ich sage mal einen Schießplatz, äh der der der Artillerie äh äh Australiens und in der australischen Wüste wurden dann die ersten Testversuche.
Äh durchgeführt.
Grad mal geguckt, also
Alldauer war ja noch bis 63 Bundeskanzler, hätte es äh fast fast noch die Vermutung gehabt, dass er so in seinen späten Jahren vielleicht nicht mehr so der Richtige gewesen wäre, um solche Entscheidungen wirklich nach vorne zu bringen in
Frankreich war's äh Josh äh Pompedu. Aber letztlich.
Stand ja die Politik auch dahinter, hinter diesem Projekt und das führte dann zur Gründung der der SRO.
Das führte zur Gründung der ESO als als äh Weltraumforschungsorganisation, das war unkritisch, ja. Da also kritisch war's Eldo, ja? Äh also die Upin Lange die Trägerraketen äh Organisationen, weil das sehr viel stärker
Politnationale politische Interessen im Vordergrund stand.
Wer baut das.
Wer baut das Wirtschaft und vor allen Dingen ähm
das sogenannte fair return oder da Einzug hielt, also zu sagen wir zahlen
in die europäische Raumfahrt ein und die Briten äh sozusagen zahlten durch ihre erste Stufe ein. Die Franzosen durch ihre zweite Stufe, die Deutschen zahlten netto, ist sozusagen Bargeld, wenn man zu will ein äh und dieses fair Return-Prinzip, das in der Raumfahrt so äh
ähm wie hast du zu seinem Sofa? Problematisch gewirkt hat, bedeutet eben, dann wollen wir möglichst viel wieder raushaben.
An Aufträgen für unsere nationale Industrie. Wir wollen wir geben ein bisschen Geld rein, aber wir äh wir wollen eigentlich schon gar nicht so richtig unser Wissen da reingeben. Das halten wir eigentlich hinter der Braut-Brandmauer, wann immer es geht.
Ja
und ähm äh sozusagen die Europäisierung war eine sehr langsame und eine sehr verzögerte und äh im Grunde eine kontrollierte.
Und und das äh.
Dieser ganze Protektionismus, der da immer noch lebt.
Ganze Protektionismus, ja? Ja also sozusagen die äh die äh die das geistige Eigentum möglichst zu kontrollieren, um um die Zukunftsfähigkeit nicht in äh nicht nicht äh zu europäieren.
Und sicherlich natürlich auch der die einfach die ja Vorbehalte den anderen Ländern gegenüber, mit denen man so viel Krieg äh geführt hat, so speziell natürlich Deutschland, aber auch die Franzosen und die Briten waren sicher auch nicht unbedingt immer grün.
Und dieses führte im Grunde zum technischen Scheitern äh der ersten äh.
Europäischen äh Phase der der Raumfahrtintegration. Weil diese europäische Trägererei.
Die dann aufgesetzt wurde und die bezeichnende Weise, ja, circa programmatisch Europa hieß. Ja, also die hieß.
Einerseits Eldo A, aber sie ist eigentlich Europa, ja? Sozusagen da wurde die Europarakete im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes an den.
Ähm und äh uns scheiterte kläglich und sie scheiterte eben an dieser an diesem sozusagen Nationalisierungs
Vorbehalt und und ganz konkret zeigt sich das und dass es einen so wunderbare äh Geschichte, dass man sie immer wieder gerne erzählt. Sie sie zeigte sich eben.
Ganz konkreten technischen Desaster, das also stattfand äh äh sich ereignete, als diese Test-Rak.
Ersten Mal in ihrer kompletten Größe am äh am Start war. Ja, die erste Stufe äh wurde mehrfach sozusagen getestet und es waren mehr Fehlschläge als äh alles andere, genauso die zweite und daraus hat man ein bisschen gelernt und dann hat man endlich auch die dritte, also die deutsche Stufe dann mit drauf gesetzt und den italienischen Satelliten
und an den Start gebracht und äh da sah also das war dann ähm neunzehnhundertsiebzig.
Dann.
In Bumerang, äh und äh.
Alle Hoffnungen richteten sich auf diese Rakete. Also Europa äh zum ersten Mal.
Neu zusammengebaut.
Ready ja neu zusammengebaut im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes integriert. Dritter äh Dritter an den Start und äh schießt sich äh äh in die Zukunft der Raumfahrt. Und nach 26 Sekunden,
zunächst mal erfolgreich aus äh explodierte die erste Stufe, ein paar Sekunden äh später die zweite Stufe und dann die dritte Stufe und was war was war der Grund? Der Hauptgrund war, dass äh die Briten, das war Malconi,
in diese dritte deutsche Stufe ihre Telemetrie einbauen mussten und die Deutschen hatten überhaupt gar kein das war eine Blackbox, die sozusagen in der deutschen,
angebracht war und die Deutschen hatten keine Ahnung, was da eigentlich äh sozusagen technisch vor sich,
ähm und äh insofern stimmt äh stimmten einfach die die Verknüpfung nicht, die Telemetrie äh äh antwortete nicht aufeinander und äh und äh und das Ding explodiert.
Weil ich sage mal die Briten nicht mit den deutschen Sprachen.
Oder weil ihr weil nicht alle dieselbe Sprache gesprochen haben.
Nicht alle dieselbe Sprache sprechen wollten durften im Grunde äh politisch vorgegeben.
Erinnert mich so ein bisschen an dieses äh Disaster, was war's? Äh eine Maß war's eine Maß äh Rakete,
äh der Amerikaner, die letzten Endes daran gescheitert ist, dass an irgendeiner Stelle halt noch das imperiale Maßsystem verwendet wurde und nicht das metrische System so und dann.
Brach's auch auseinander.
Aber da war's sozusagen noch willentlicher. Das war jetzt nicht nur äh sozusagen, weil man etwas nicht bedachte, sondern weil man das äh äh apriori so konstruierte, dass äh dass der eine nicht mit dem anderen spricht, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Ähm und.
Schönes Bild. So, Europa kann nicht funktionieren, wenn wir nicht eine Sprache.
Und und vor allen Dingen kann's nicht funktionieren, wenn die Politik der Wissenschaft und Technik ständig reinredet, ja.
Das war die große ähm sozusagen
Lernkurve, die man doch laufen musste und da auf der sich dann sozusagen der Erfolg in der er in der zweiten Phase europäischer Raumfahrt in den 70er und 80er Jahren auf.
Man die Eser ganz anders konstruierte. Diese Eldo äh da gab's immer sozusagen den Vorbehalt der Politik. Die die entschieden und äh die,
neudeutsch gesprochen, Governance, der ähm der älter politisch dominiert während
dann die Governance der der Isar sozusagen von der Wissenschaft, von der letztendlich von der Autonomie der Wissenschaft und
Technik äh lebt, ja und das also man man muss die Entscheidungshoheit wieder zurückgeben in,
wissenschaftlich und technische Hände in das Management, so wie sie die ESA heute aufgebaut ist. Dann gibt's sozusagen drüber den Ministerrat äh der äh der Beteiligten dieser Einrichtung und die finanzieren und besprechen die ähm.
Politischen äh nicht.
Konstruktion der der politischen Konstruktion die Details, aber nicht die technischen Details. Das ist das ist sozusagen in den Händen von Wissenschaften und Technik und das war die große Lernkurve. Ja und das und und zweitens, dass dieses fair Return-Prinzip äh nach Möglichkeit nicht,
nicht greifen sollte, weil das immer wieder eine repolitisierung von Wissenschaft und Technik bedeutet.
Das heißt, dieses European Launcher Developement organisation diese Eldo war eigentlich so der erste europäische Versuch und der ist eigentlich erst mal gescheitert, was dann vielleicht am Ende auch,
gut war, aber das ist ja dann im Prinzip für sind ja die sechziger Jahre, während ja die Amerikaner mit dem Apollo-Programm
ihre großen Durchbruch äh feierten und die Russen jetzt auch nicht ganz unerfolgreich waren, auch wenn's äh erstmal nicht bis zum Mond gereicht hat.
Europäer eigentlich im Wesentlichen mit sich selbst beschäftigt und ähm ja haben eigentlich nichts äh auf Kette bekommen. Also Eldo wurde 62 einberufen gegen 64 dann erst so richtig äh.
An Staat und äh dann halt eben dieses Desaster mit der Europa äh Rakete, was dann.
71 das letzte Mal ähm stattgefunden hat oder beziehungsweise nicht stattgefunden hat und dann.
Hat Europa gesagt, okay, alles klar, so funktioniert's offensichtlich nicht. Wir müssen das jetzt alles wieder neu aufstellen und das war ja dann im Prinzip die Geburt der Esar.
Das war die Geburt der ESA. Also nach diesem äh vernichtenden Untersuchungsreport, wo alle sagen, okay so äh wir sehen's jetzt wirklich auch auf der technischen Ebene. So kann's nicht weitergehen. Wir brauchen eine neue Konstruktion, dann gab's einen sogenannten.
Stiel äh indem man also die ISO äh ESO die funktionierte, weil da also
da war die Politik in der Weltraumforschung äh in das Satelliten äh Missionsplanung war die äh Politik weitgehend außen vor. Da konnten die Wissenschaftler untereinander reden und und auch schön dem äh gelungenen Missionen aufsetzen, die dann mit amerikanischen Träger äh Raketen geflogen wurden
Das funktionierte gut ähm und äh das musste natürlich politisch ausbalanciert werden. Die äh.
In äh ihre Interessen, die Franzosen hatten ihre Interessen, die Deutschen und so weiter und so fort und äh das zu harmonisieren war ein ziemlich schwieriger Akt dann 197172 aber auf,
dieses Desasters, ja weil man äh sozusagen das war der Schlag äh äh kräftige Beweis, so geht's nicht weiter. Wir müssen was Neues machen und wir müssen, wie gesagt, Verantwortung rückverlagern in die Wissenschaft und so wurde dann in diesem
Stil zwischen der Mitgliedsorganisation, äh die ist er aufgesetzt und äh zu einer überlebensfähigen Organisation gemacht. Und dann konnte das Ariane-Programm.
Werden.
Wenn man jetzt, weil wir sprechen ja immer von Europa, so. Das damalige Europa war ja im Wesentlichen das westliche Europa und auch nicht.
Raumfahrt Europa war ja jetzt auch nicht zwingend identisch äh mit dem,
EU-Europa oder damals halt noch der europäischen äh Gemeinschaft ähm beziehungsweise zu dem Zeitpunkt war es wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal die europäische Gemeinschaft, sondern deren Vorgängerorganisation auf jeden Fall Europa hat sich ja äh.
Quasi vielfältig entwickelt und wenn man auch heute so auf die ganzen einzelnen europäischen nicht nur die Raumfahrtorganisationen, sondern überhaupt was es so an,
Vereinigungen äh so gibt in allen Bereichen anschaut. Ist immer so ein Flickenteppich. Ist mal irgendeiner. Ist nicht dabei. Das ist ja immer ganz anderes dabei und manchmal geht es auch ein bisschen über Europa hinaus und manchmal ist es wirklich extrem Kerneuropa.
Klar, viel dreht sich halt immer um Deutschland, Italien, Frankreich und Großbritannien. Aber ähm.
Wie war es denn bei der ESA? Also welcher europäische Gedanke steckte hier drin? Wer waren die treibenden Kräfte und wie hat man die anderen? Warum hat man noch andere Länder dazu genommen?
Ja sie haben Recht auch das Europa der Raumfahrt ist eines von
nenne das mal multiple Geografien der europäischen Raumfahrt äh äh Kooperation. Da gibt's äh das ähm äh Europa der ESA und es gibt ein Europa der nordischen Kooperation äh Raumfahrtforschungskooperation. Es gibt
bilaterale Kooperation deutsche, französische Achse mit vielen ähm äh Projekten und da ist eines,
wenn ich das so auch äh sozusagen antworten darf, dass ich so ein paar Geschichten erzähle, weil sie so instruktiv sind. Ähm
und und doch auch Ihre Frage beantworten, weil die zwei Haupttriebkräfte äh der der Isar und der europäischen Raumfahrt äh Kooperation wie wie.
Uns vor Augen haben, wenn wir an ähm große Brüh.
Dann ist das Frankreich und Deutschland. Also zeigt das Sachsen-Europa ist auch in der Raumfahrt sind die beiden äh äh Triebfedern, die sozusagen die zentrifugalen Kräfte der europäischen Raumfahrt.
Kooperation immer wieder einfangen mussten und kontrollieren mussten durch die sozusagen Elysee äh Achse äh in den 70er und achtziger Jahren.
Ganz im im Speziellen drohte auch die Isar immer wieder auseinander zu fallen und es bedurfte dann auch sozusagen oberster politischer äh Protektion und da musste der Bundeskanzler äh mit dem französischen Staatspräsidenten reden.
Um äh äh die Isar wieder zu stabilisieren. Können wir gerade Mitte der 80er Jahre ist da so eine Phase als das sogenannte Zukunftsprogramm der ESA ähm in einem komplexen äh.
Politischen Prozess stabilisiert werden musste und auf auf die Schiene gehoben war, aufs Gleis gesetzt wurde. Wie sagt man das? Eigentlich ein falsches Bild, passt alles nicht. Ähm.
Dass äh da brauchte es oberste politische Unterstützung und das war immer Frankreich und Deutschland. Also das ist schon
schon die Achse. Aber wie gesagt, wir haben auch ein Europa ein äh der der nordischen äh äh,
skandinavischen äh Kooperationen äh wo äh äh Norwegen äh und und Schweden und Finnland miteinander kooperierten. Und wir haben eben Bilatrale Kooperationen zum Beispiel im.
Deutschland äh und.
Frankreich, äh im Telekommunikations äh äh Bereich, die die ersten Satelliten, die hier aufgesetzt worden sind. Das waren immer unterschiedliche Geografien der europäischen Raumfahrt.
Aber nochmal Deutschland und Frankreich sind die sind die zwei äh Achsenmächten. Äh der ich der der europäischen Raumfahrt äh.
Zusammenarbeit. Ja, aber wie Sie sagen, es geht natürlich hinaus über das politische Europa. Da ist dann auch äh da ist dann äh Österreich mit eingebo,
und da ist äh wird die Schweiz eingebunden. Ja und wir haben wir haben's ja generell gehört, da ist äh sogar Australien zunächst mal eingebunden und dann ist Französisch-Guyana eingebunden. Also insofern.
Äh die äh Geografie äh Europas und des politischen Europas überhaupt nicht einher mit der der europäischen Raumfahrtkooperation und natürlich ist Europa immer wieder auch angewiesen auf die USA.
Also die sozusagen eine europäische Raumfahrt arbeitet sich ab an der NASA.
Ein Gegengewicht gegen die NASA aufbauen, äh wird aber immer wieder auch ähm sozusagen zu einer Kooperation mit den USA gezwungen. Das heißt, wenn die europäischen Trägerraketen nicht funktionieren, sei es im Postapolo-Programm,
äh äh dann äh wo man äh gemeinsam schon mal in Richtung Raumstation anfängt zu planen et cetera. Und dann, Sie haben's äh genannt, gibt es natürlich das im Kalten Krieg das Gegenstück.
Raumfahrtkooperation äh östlicher äh Manier sozusagen und das ist das Intekosmosprogramm, das die äh Sowjetunion aufgesetzt hat, um ihre Satellitenstaaten
einzubinden in ein Kooperations äh Programm äh mit mit vielen, vielen äh gemeinsamen Aktivitäten.
Jetzt äh ist natürlich die Frage, was ist das für eine Kooperation? Äh wie können wir die heute
aus der äh Rückschau äh betrachten, ist das eine Kooperation auf
gleichem Fuse, so wie sie doch bei der ESA im Wesentlichen herstellt und die Deutschen mit den Franzosen und und Briten sozusagen auf Augenhöhe äh kopiert.
Schon mit eigenen Interessen, aber es ist klar, jeder bringt sich dann doch äh äh zugunsten eines gemeinsamen Zieles ein,
äh nein, das war natürlich in äh im Ostblock nicht der Fall, sondern da war die die klare Suprematie der der Sowjetunion, die die.
Regeln, vorgab und die ihre Satelliten.
Einband und äh sagte okay, ihr in der DDR macht das, ihr macht das Institut für Kosmosforschung, ihr macht die die Kamera, die und und äh,
die äh die Tschechins oder die Tschechoslowakei macht das und das aufbauend auf auf ihren äh Kernkompetenzen.
Und so weiter. Also ähm wir beschreiben das heute fast schon als sozusagen koloniale Kooperation, ja, sozusagen wir moderne äh äh Imperialismus oder Kolonialismus und die Sowjetunion ganz knapp ganz klar vor
wer was zu machen hat und der Spielraum, der äh äh Comicron-Staaten, also Mitgliedsstaaten, das ist,
äh sozusagen Wirtschafts- und Wissenschaftsverbunds im im Osten äh der war gering und die USA äh die Sowjetunion war so
klar der Treiber und derjenige, der alles vorgab. Aber trotzdem in de Kosmos ist sozusagen das äh osteuropäische Gegenstieg Stück zur Esar im Westen.
War also die Esa geboren und äh hatte natürlich das Ziel besser zu funktionieren als vorher. Die Politik hat die Leine etwas lockerer gelassener.
Wissenschaft, da mischen wir uns jetzt mal nicht so äh ein, kooperiert ihr mal fleißig, äh aber wir müssen jetzt ja auch mal äh Ergebnisse erzielen als da sicherlich auch,
ganze Geld, was da reingegeben wurde, wollte man natürlich dann Erfolge auch sehen. Wie hat denn die Eser dann quasi sich neu.
Aufgestellt, als sie dann gegründet war und vor allem, wenn ich's richtig sehe, ist ja diese Eldo, diese Lautschalgeschichte mehr oder weniger aufgelöst und in die Isar über äh gegangen.
Heute ist allerdings der ganze Raketenbereich bei Arianes-Bass äh angesiedelt. Wie kam's denn zu dieser Ausgliederung?
Ja, das ist, wenn man so will jetzt äh äh der technisch, der ökonomische Arm, äh
der Esel, aber die ESA als als ähm Organisation, jetzt ist ja in sie hat die Headquarter in äh.
Paris in und da ist sozusagen die General Sitz die Generaldirektion äh der ESA die dann eigentlich einen eigenen.
Aufbauen kann, der unabhängig ist von den Mitglieds.
Die eine eigene bürokratische Logik entwickeln können und die natürlich dann auch wiederum irgendwelchen politischen Interessen äh,
müssen, indem nicht alle Organisationen,
Paris konzentriert äh werden. Da ist die Generaldirektion, aber dafür sitzen die technischen äh Facilities an anderer Stelle. Die sitzen in Darmstadt. Die sitzen in äh Oberpfaffenhofen hier in der Nähe von München. Das Kontrollzentrum. Die sitzen in Nordwijk, äh in den Niederlanden, wo äh sozusagen
äh im Wesentlichen der Technikkomplex äh verortet ist und so weiter und es gibt die S-Range und äh also es gibt Standort der europäische Kooperation, die über die Mitgliedsstaaten,
um diese.
Politische Architektur der Raumfahrtkooperation zu stabilisieren. Weil jedes Mitgliedsland dann doch eben schaut, wir zahlen so und so viel ein, was haben wir denn davon? Wir müssen um das vor unseren Steuerzahlern,
rechtfertigen und da reicht sozusagen die philosophische Idee der europäischen Integration nicht aus. Irgendwas ökonomisches muss da auch zurückkommen,
Trotzdem, es bleibt die Generaldirektion
ist sozusagen autark und sie kann die technischen Entscheidungen treffen. Sie ist berichtspflichtig gegenüber der Politik, aber die Politik.
Direkt reinreden und äh dafür gibt's eine Arbeitsteilung. Die Politik ist wie gesagt im E im ESA Ministerrat repräsentiert und die trifft sich äh.
Je periodisch treffen sich die jeweiligen äh Wissenschaftsminister oder zuständigen Ministerien um zu besprechen äh wie wie und was man finanziert.
Aber was konkret gemacht wird und wie es gemacht wird, das ist eben der Vorbehalt äh äh von Wissenschaft und Technik.
Ähm und und diese sozusagen komplexe Konstellation, die funktioniert einigermaßen
und äh die gerät immer wieder sozusagen unter politischen Bewährungsdruck, wenn das Geld knapp wird, wenn man viel Geld einsammeln muss. Jetzt komme ich doch auf Mitte der 80er Jahre zu sprechen als
eben die bemannte Raumfahrt ähm in Europa sozusagen ausgebaut wurde als die
International Space Station zur Entscheidung an Stand als viele als Ariane fünf
als sozusagen zukunftsfähige Trägerrakete zur Diskussion stand. Da musste viel Geld auf den Tisch,
äh werden und da bedurfte es dann also wie gesagt äh eigentlich des Eingreifens auch wiederum der deutschen und französischen ähm Regierung.
Um äh die anderen Mitgliedsstaaten wieder ins Boot zu holen und zu sagen und gerade insbesondere die die Briten, die immer äh ja ein Auge drauf hatten, wie viel zahlen sie nach Europa ein und was kriegen sie zurück, um dieses Zukunfts äh Programm,
aus der Taufe zu heben und wie es der Zufall will, war damals der Vorsitzende dieses ähm ESA Ministerrats.
Deutsche äh Forschungsminister Heinz Riesenhuber, der dann ähm sozusagen.
An die Hand genommen wurde, auch von seinem Bundeskanzler und sagt, du machst das jetzt und du bringst bringst dieses Programm an den Start.
Und äh wie es der Zufall will, war ein Generaldirektor, der damalige Generaldirektor der Esar auch ein Deutscher, Reimanlüst äh
eben als Präsident der Max-Planck-Gesellschaft, der dann ähm äh nach Paris ging und die beiden konnten miteinander und haben das dann sozusagen dieses Zukunftsprogramm, wo viele
sozusagen auch heute noch am Start äh befindlichen Module der europäischen Raumfahrt. Ariane fünf.
Geboren wurden, äh oben das auf der Taufe, aus der Taufe und stabilisierten da die europäische Raumfahrt. Das war so ein Scharnier-Moment europäischer Raumfahrt.
Aber es fing ja nicht mit der Ariane fünf an, sondern es war ja im Prinzip, weil die die eigentliche Wiedergeburt der europäischen Raumfahrt, die dann mal konkret durchgeführt werden konnte, war ja dann die Entwicklung der Ariane.
Raketen, nachdem das ganze ELO-Projekt äh schief gegangen ist, ähm wurde dann halt neue Entwicklungen aufgenommen.
Isar hat sich jetzt äh konstituiert, wann war das jetzt nochmal.
27, genau und 79 flog dann die erste Areale. Das heißt, das waren dann erst mal so sieben Jahre, weitere sieben Jahre nach dem verlorenen zehn Jahren, die man im Prinzip noch mal.
Weiter hungern musste, sprich Europa waren so unterm Strich mal grob gesagt, äh zwei Dekaden eigentlich zum.
Nicht auf dieser Landkarte, auf der sie unbedingt immer sein wollte, während die anderen äh weitere Erfolge erzielten.
Das ist richtig, was die Träger ähm
Konstruktion von Trägerraketen betrifft. Äh das sozusagen ist äh zu äh wird ein Kompliment her äh ist ist die Weltraum
Forschung zu sehen und da war natürlich Satelliten ähm Projekte schon unterwegs äh insbesondere auch in der Erdbeobachtung
die sozusagen Erfolge versprachen, die aber dann wie gesagt mit amerikanischen Trägerraketen zuerst beifliegen mussten
und ähm und auch das war nicht einfach. Das zeigt sich bei einem mit einer deutsch-amerikanischen äh Kooperation Helios.
Ein wunderbares Projekt äh zum Bau von zwei Sonnensorten, ja, also äh Sonden, die um die Sonne herumfliegen sollten.
Und zum ersten Mal eigentlich im Grunde die die die Sonne äh der Sonne nahe kommen sollten um um die Sonne zu erforschen. Diese zwei Helios ist ja der griechische Gott äh der Sonne äh und äh das musste.
Politisch auf die Schiene gesetzt werden und da.
Auch sehr spannende Geschichte. Da flog äh der damalige Bundeskanzler äh Ehardt ähm Anfang der siebziger Jahre
äh in die USA um äh mit der amerikanischen Regierung im Grunde eine Art äh.
Was habe ich gesagt? Siebziger Entschuldigung, das war neunzehnhundert äh sechsundsechzig, siebenundsechzig flog äh Erhardt in die USA und mit dem äh amerikanischen Präsident Linie Johnson
und das war die äh das war so die erste
ich sage mal Budgetkrise in der bundesdeutschen Geschichte, erste Wirtschafts kleine Wirtschaftskrise, 19sechsund6, 67 um ähäh zu verhandeln über eine Reduzierung
der amerikanischen Stationierungskosten in Deutschland. Die Deutschen mussten bezahlen dafür, dass die Amerikaner äh so hohe Truppenkosten in Europa hatten, in Deutschland, insbesondere hatten und da wollte er äh Umstundung, sage ich jetzt mal, von Zahlungen äh.
Äh Lyndon wie Johnson, die sind völlig auflaufen und bot ihm an
Na ja gut, wir können mit euch eine Raumfahrtkooperation machen. Was was haltet ihr da davon, wenn wir euch dieses anbieten? Wir machen gemeinsam ein ein äh Experiment der Sonne äh Forschung und dann kam also ein äh ziemlich frustrierter.
Bundeskanzler zurück und brachte das im Gepäck mit. Die deutschen Raumfahrtingenieure freuten sich und bauten das. Es flog dann 1975 beide beide Satelliten ähm waren sehr, war eine sehr erfolgreiche.
Mission und das äh das Schwingungsmodell. Also wenn man so will, das Objekt, das am nächsten dem Original kommt.
Steht heute in der Raumfahrtausstellung des deutschen Museums.
Äh aber es zeigt einmal mehr wie wie politisch äh verknüpft dann doch Raumfahrtprojekte sind und immer wieder abhängig sind von äh von Interessen jenseits wissenschaftlich politischer Logiken.
Und ähm,
nochmal äh deswegen dauerte das auch länger in in Europa um um dieses europäische Raumfahrt immer wieder da äh sozusagen äh kontrollieren zu können und äh und und die politische Umarmung und Einlegung
möglichst äh einzudämmen. Aber Sie haben's genannt. Ähm äh europäische Trägererke
Ariane besichtigt die Ariane Familie von Trägerraketen mal wirtschaftlich nicht nur wirtschaftlich, sondern auch technisch bewähren konnte, dauerte einige Jahre und insofern sind diese Satellitenmissionen sozusagen vorausgeeilt und haben zunächst mal gezeigt
was eine europäische Raumfahrt äh Kooperation kann, bevor ähm die Ariane-Familie an den Start ging.
Also ich meinte ja so.
Dass das quasi äh diese verlorene Zeit dann mehr oder weniger mit dem Start der Rakete dahingehend endet, als dass man eben eine
klare Vision auf eine eigenständige Raumfahrt hatte, selbst wenn man natürlich viele Kooperationen macht. Die Zeit dazwischen, die mit Satellitenentwicklung genutzt wurde, hat ja dann auch letzten Endes der ESA die Nischen,
quasi äh eröffnet, die sie heute ja auch noch wunderbar,
füllt, also während natürlich die Amerikaner bei so den deep Space und Mond äh Explorationen lange Zeit ganz vorne waren, die Russen natürlich auch.
Blieb dann quasi für die Esar dann so die Erde übrig und man hat sich so diese low owbit Mission ausgesucht und heutzutage ist natürlich die Erdbeobachtung so ein
großes, wichtiges Feld für die ESA geworden und hat natürlich auch als solche eine extreme Bedeutung, sodass es dann langfristig auch nicht unbedingt alles von Nachteil war.
Sehr gute Interpretation, die zeigt, dass äh äh Europa da also auch die Zeichen der Zeit nutzte, ja die siebziger Jahre sind die Jahre auch der Entdeckung der Umweltprobleme ähm.
Ähm 19dreiundsiebzig Club of Froam äh
äh Limits to crowd et cetera. Also die formierende Umweltbewegung, äh die die dann sozusagen ja auch sich zeigt in den
in der Erde Beobachtung in den Umweltmissionen äh und da ist Europa führend geworden und sozusagen auszu ja wenn man so will, aus der Not heraus ein eigenständiges Profil.
Entwickelt und also insofern sind diese verlorenen Kosten dann äh doch in sozusagen in ein äh eine erfolgreiche Lernkurve überführt worden und haben Europa.
Grade in im im Bereich der Weltraumforschung nach vorne gebracht.
Wo's ja dann richtig gut lief, war ja dann eben die die Ariane,
Rakete oder die äh die Serie von äh Ariane äh Raketen, nachdem man das erste Mal geschafft hat überhaupt zu starten sich vor allem auch so ein
glaube sehr extrem beneidenswerten Startplatz geschaffen hat mit Corona ist es natürlich einfach mal so der beste Ort, den man so.
Auf dem Planeten so finden kann für den Stadtplatz weil er einfach mit Abstand derjenige ist der am nächsten zum Äquator ist und von daher die Wucht der äh Erde am besten mitnehmen kann, was ja.
Ganze Menge Spritsparte et cetera. Ähm das.
Macht auf mich so den Eindruck als ob hier dann auf einmal alles sehr gut zusammengelaufen ist, dass diese ganze europäische Kooperation gut funktioniert hat, dass man äh die Ressourcen irgendwie klug genutzt hat, weil die Ariane.
Fünf, die ja in gewisser Hinsicht so bis heute noch am am Ende dieser Entwicklung steht, auch wenn wir jetzt kurz theoretisch zumindest kurz vor der Ariane äh sechs sind.
Dann so über zwei Jahrzehnte einfach auch bewiesen hat, jetzt nicht nur eine sehr leistungsfähige Rakete zu sein für die damaligen Verhältnisse, vor allem auch extrem zuverlässig. Also das ist einfach während die russische Raumfahrt ähm.
Die Auswirkungen der neunziger Jahre nicht so gut verarbeitet bekommen hat und ja eine Serie von Kleinstkatastrophen äh aneinander äh hintereinander gelegt hat, die Amerikaner sich lange Zeit von,
Space Shuttle äh Desaster nicht so richtig äh erholt haben und ihre Prioritäten wieder neu ordnen äh mussten. Das war ja dann im Prinzip eigentlich so die Phase, wo Europa dann seine Kraft auch voll ausspielen konnte und sich zu sein,
äh den Platz auf der Landkarte jetzt aber auch wirklich mal mit einem dicken Edding äh markiert hat.
Das ist das ist alles richtig. Vielleicht äh mit der äh kleinen Einschränkung, dass die
russische Raumfahrt äh schon auch gezeigt hat, dass sie robuste Technologie äh machen kann. Vielleicht keine Advanced äh und und keine keine äh besonders innovativen, fortgeschrittenen Technologien, aber sehr leistungsfähige, sehr,
äh wie sagt man da, das das gutmütige Pferd, äh dass es schafft äh da sozusagen klassische.
Die Sojus hat halt hat auch gut gehalten.
Hat gehalten und äh hat dann natürlich auch sich schon ein ein äh auch nach der äh Transformation äh also nach Glas Nost et cetera sich schon auch ein ein
am Platz ähm äh am Markt der Trägerraketen gesichert ja und.
Aber trotzdem gab's ja jetzt diese diese Phase, wo dann wirklich sehr viele Missionen äh verloren gegangen, sind Marsmissionen, die nicht geklappt haben, teilweise in orbindlich erreicht haben ähm
am Startplatz explodiert. Also es sind eigentlich so die die volle Kette, die man äh.
Nicht haben will, während halt in Europa eigentlich so über zwei Jahrzehnte lang alles einfach lief, so Ariane startet. Man konnte Urlauber stellen. Äh die kamen irgendwie pünktlich hoch und es gab äh selten Probleme.
Es gab selten Probleme. So ist es. Und ich ich glaube, dass äh ja, das ist ähm.
Schon so zu sehen, dass das die Auswirkungen sind dieser Lernkurve ja heute sozusagen die Lessons learnt. Äh wie gesagt.
Mit viel Geld, das versenkt worden ist äh und das in europäischen äh Steuerzahler Geld gekostet hat, aber man hat daraus die richtigen Konsequenzen gezogen und äh hat die äh ähm.
Die adäquaten ähm äh Technologien aufgesetzt und ist tatsächlich geschafft, dieses schwierige Management und ich glaube, das ist die spezielle Herausforderung. Management von.
Raumfahrtprogramm in den Griff zu bekommen. Ähm wir äh.
Wir reden vom Apollo-Programm ähm das so als Erfolgsgeschichte dastehen,
äh und vergessen dabei, dass wenn ich ihn noch mal auf Werner von Braun zurückkomme
dass das amerikanische Apollo-Programm äh Mitte der 60er-jahre im Grunde fast äh scheitern äh zu scheitern, drohte daran, dass im Grunde Werner von Braun seine Penemünde-Idee überzogen hat und ihn das Ap,
implantieren wollte.
Äh nicht realisieren wollte, dass er völlig überfordert war mit seiner Idee, alles unter einem Dach. Er hat seine paar tausend äh Peemünder, die ihm sozusagen zuarbeiten und alles noch kontrollieren, um mit dem macht er die Apollo.
Ja und oder die die Saturn fünf. Das konnte überhaupt nicht funktionieren und scheiterte und es brauchte die amerikanische Airforce.
Äh ganz andere Erfahrung hatte und ganz andere Kompetenzen hatte.
Wie solche äh komplexen Projekte äh zu handeln sind, zu managen sind, nämlich durch contracting, ja. Da gibt man Boeing was und gibt man äh äh crumen was et cetera und.
Sozusagen arbeitet mit äh mit verteilten Aufgaben und und und sozusagen.
Das ganze Land ein in ein solches Komplett und die ganze nationale Industrie, in ein solch komplexes Projekt Mustern, aber dieses Projektmanagement handeln und sicherstellen, dass Boing rechtzeitig geliefert und dass äh no.
Norbert Crumon äh äh rechtzeitig liefert und das alles sozusagen dann zu managen.
Hatte die amerikanische Air Force mit ihren Großprojekten viel Erfahrung und das brauchte es.
Um äh um um Apollo dann an den Start zu bringen und da wurde damals eigentlich Werner von Braun weitgehend ausgebotet, weil er nicht in der Lage war ein solches Modell anzubieten.
Daraus haben die Europäer auch ihre Lehren gezogen und äh,
eben dieses contracting was wir ja sehen Nordwijk was stattfindet, dass in Darmstadt was stattfindet, dass in ähm Oberpfaffenhofen, wir haben's genannt, was stattfindet und das zu einem gemeinsamen ähm sozusagen
ineinandergreifenden Räderwerk auf äh auszubauen und die Vorteile zu nutzen, dass
dass Italien Kompetenzen hat und Deutschland spezifische Kompetenzen hat et cetera, die gemeinsam gebündelt eben dann zu einer Stärke führen. Das war die Stärke und das war die
Ähm das war die Voraussetzung dafür, dass das Ayanne-Projekt ein solch erfolgreiches Technologie-Kooperationsunternehmen geworden ist.
Bringt mir auch einen interessanten Punkt. Das ist ja auch mehr äh äh das europäische Raumfahrtprogramm ja auch mehr ist als nur die
Und ihre Standorte, sondern dass er auch hier äh im Prinzip eine entsprechende Industrie auch gestartet werden muss.
Gibt ja auch noch ein zweites Erfolgsprojekt europäischer Natur, das äh Airbusprogramm und ja die erste große Konzern, der daraus hervorgegangen ist äh
spielt ja auch in der Raumfahrt heute im Satellitenbau eine eine große Rolle. Ist auch nicht der einzige Player. Aber es ist halt auch über die Zeit gelungen, auch eine Industrie heranzuziehen, die in Europa auch in der Lage ist, eben nicht nur
also man hat nicht nur eine Organisation, die Missionen planen kann und Anforderungen machen kann, Instrumente bauen kann, sondern es müssen halt auch die Satelliten gebaut werden
die letzten Endes erfolgreich diese Mission ausführen.
Bedeutungen haben diese Unternehmen und wie sind die in dieses politische Geflecht auch mit eingebunden, sodass es
trotzdem auch noch ein privates Space sein kann.
Ja, das ist eine äh schwierige Frage, wo ist gar nicht so viel Forschung dazu gibt. Also gerade auch die europäische Industriekooperation.
Die äh sowohl jetzt was Airbus betrifft ähm als auch was ähm Allianz Bass betrifft. Da ähm.
Noch wenig wenig dazu bekannt, äh was da die die Problemlagen waren und da war's sozusagen wie diese Integration auch tatsächlich funktioniert hat unter unternehmerischen Vorzeichen. Ich will mal ich will mal so ein bisschen antworten, indem ich für
ausweichend antworten, indem ich äh noch mal das Gegenbeispiel zeige, nämlich wie Raumfahrtmanagement in Deutschland funktionierte oder auch nicht funktionierte, um zu zeigen, welche Voraussetzungen eigentlich für Erfolg bestehen müssen.
In Deutschland eigentlich bis zur Gegenwart. Ein riesiges Problem äh ein adäquates äh Raumfahrtmanagement.
Gleisen und das ist seit Ende der oder seit der zweiten Hälfte der 60er Jahre so als als sozusagen Europa begann und als man auch in Deutschland nationale Projekte jenseits der europäischen Raumfahrt ähm
aufzugleisen begann Azur war der erste deutsche Forschungssatellite et cetera, da brauchte man ja eine Agentur, die das managt.
Und dann wurde äh verzweifelt nach möglichen Modellen für eine deutsche NASA sozusagen gesucht und äh dann hat man nach deutschem Gesellschaftsrecht eine GmbH zunächst mal gegründet
ist dann Gesellschaft für Weltraumforschung und da gab's zwei äh Teilhaber. Der der Bund.
Als Mehrheitsgesellschafter und eine Privatperson, ein Bänker, der der äh zweite Gesellschafter war.
Ein heillos gescheitertes äh Projekt, aber wurden dann Beamte eingestellt, die also Raumfahrtenmanagement betreiben sollte. Äh ich sage mal ehemalige Bundes äh Forschungs äh Ministeriumsreferenten.
Funktionierte nicht. Da zog man 1969 dann
Als insgesamt die Architektur äh institutionelle Architektur der der Raumfahrt und äh auch der Luftfahrtforschung in Deutschland verändert wurde und das
heutige DLR damals hieß das deutsche Forschungszentrum für Luft-und Raumfahrt gegründet wurde. 1968, 69.
Heißt ja auch heute noch so. Deutsches Zentrum für Lufthut.
Damals dieses deutsches Forschungs-und Versuchsanstalt für Luft und Raumfahrt und jetzt ist das deutsche Zentrum äh DLR rausgewählt worden. Damals hieß es DFV LR sehr sehr äh.
Schwierige Abkürzung.
Naja, jedenfalls äh meinte man dann, okay, jetzt lagert man das Raumfahrtmanagement in diese neue Einheits äh äh Organisation der Luft- und Raumfahrtforschung in Deutschland ein. 19neun6und bis 72 war das dann der Raumfahrttechnische Bereich dieser DVLR.
Und da sagte die Industrie, so kann das ja überhaupt nicht funktionieren.
Ihr wollt uns am Start haben im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes und ihr in der Wissenschaft kontrolliert, dass ihr habt doch ganz andere Interessen und ich habe ganz andere Erfahrung. Ihr wisst doch gar nicht, wie das geht.
Also auch das scheiterte wieder und dann äh
ähm gab's so eine Zwischenphase, wo es wieder in die Industrie hineinverlagert wurde und schließlich gründete man wiederum eine deutsche Agentur für Raumfahrtangelegenheiten in den 80er Jahren und das waren wiederum eher äh äh sozusagen Beamte.
Also dann Raumfahrtmanagement betreiben sollten, hat man tatsächlich einen ehemaligen Referenten aus dem Bundesforschungsministerium geholt, der dann also der Präsident dieser Dara, deutsche Agentur für Raumfahrtangelegenheiten war,
wieder heillos gescheitert. Die Industrie war nicht mit einverstand.
Über diese Beamte des Struktur des Raumfahrtmanagements, dann hat man die wieder abgewickelt unter hohen Kosten, dann hat's wieder zurückverlagert in das heutige DLR hinein et cetera. Also das waren viele Versuche gescheiterte Versuche
adäquates Raumfahrtmanagement äh Wirtschaft und Wissenschaft äh zu integrieren und mit der Politik als finanziert sozusagen hinzustellen. Also
ich nenne das als Negativbeispiel, um ihnen zu zeigen, wie wichtig eine adäquate,
Verflechtung von Wissenschaft und Wirtschaft und politischen Fortzeichen ist im Raumfahrtmanagement ähm äh und äh.
Wie ähm wie sehr dann sozusagen die ESA mit ihrer Kompetenz das äh auf sozusagen zu manage äh davon absticht.
Und dieser nur nochmal diese Erfahrung und diese Erfahrung, die war schmerzlich Anfang der äh in den sechziger Jahren, aber dann hat man die Konsequenzen gezogen, hat das richtig hat das artig Querquad auch unter Nutzung der industriellen.
Aufgesetzt und hinzu kommt natürlich, dass sich auch die europäische Raumfahrt äh Industrie aus sich heraus europäisierte, sozusagen in der.
Richtigen Erkenntnis, äh äh dass äh der Markt in dem Bereich zu klein ist, um für Unternehmen.
Erfolgreich äh auf nationale Ebene erarbeiten zu können. Auch da braucht man sozusagen ein ein ein eine Bündelung europäischer Interessen und vor allen Dingen Ressourcen und Kapazitäten um am Markt bestehen zu bleiben.
Management wird jetzt, glaube ich, in Deutschland vor allem vom DLR, von der Rundfahrtagentur durchgeführt. Das scheint ja ganz gut zu funktionieren soweit.
Nach nach vielen vielen äh Fehlschlägen.
Anläufen sozusagen.
Anläufen, genau und äh da irgendwann mal, glaube ich, hat man's geschafft, da doch sozusagen an einem Strang zu ziehen und da und äh und das adäquat aufzusetzen und zu zeigen, die die äh nah sein äh auch in Deutschland irgendwie.
Hinzubekommen.
Die Entwicklung ging ja dann äh für die Esa von den einfachen Satellitenmissionen auch äh dann über zur.
Zur Beteiligung an der ISS. Das war ja dann schon ein,
großer Schritt, würde ich sagen für die ESA, weil sie ja damit gemeinsam mit der Jackson und den ähm Roskosmos und eben den der NASA ja quasi so eigentlich so,
Teil des Leuchtturmprojekts der Raumfahrt schlechthin äh kann man sagen äh geworden ist. Und heute äh scheint mir die ESA vor allem auch.
Sehr viel besser vernetzt zu sein. Das ist auch das, was hier aus vielen Gesprächen immer wieder herauskommt. Amerikaner machen immer alles gerne äh.
Natürlich auch bei vielen Sachen äh nicht nur mit der ESA, ganz klar, aber zum Beispiel zu den Chinesen eine gewisse äh Distanz und wenn Russen das,
würde ich sagen jetzt komplikated äh so ja also klar bei der ISS ist man noch zusammen aber es gibt viele.
Berührungsprobleme und ich habe immer so den Vorteil, dass Europa äh,
aus dieser zweiten Reihe heraus, aus die sie gestartet sind, aber auch eben mit den eigenen Erfahrungen dieses interkulturellen Mischmaschs des Europa halt einfach immer noch ist. In gewisser Hinsicht so eine Resilienz entwickelt hat, äh aber auch so eine so eine Fähigkeit entwickelt hat, dann doch diese
Vernetzung auch mehr in sich hinein zu tragen und damit kooperativer nach außen zu wirken. Das ist lässt sich das irgendwie.
Bestätigen oder herauslesen.
Lässt sich bestätigen und ich glaube, da ist in der Tat die Stärke Europas äh äh besteht darin, dass sie transnational äh agieren und aus der Umklammerung der.
Selbst stärker heraustreten als das in den USA ist. Die NASA sitzt am Ende doch äh hängt am Gängelband der.
Ja, sie ist abhängig von von äh äh Kongressbudgets. Jedes Jahr muss das NASA-Budget, äh wie wir's jetzt auch dieser Tage wieder
erleben, wovon einem Shutdown äh in in den USA die Rede ist, neu genehmigt werden. Also der Kongress kann die NASA gängeln, wie er möchte
und äh auch die, ich sage mal die äh Prolieferations
und die die die Intellektuell äh Intellektual-Propact-Problematik ist in den USA so, dass es äh die amerikanische äh sozusagen Vorbehalt äh Wissen äh in internationale
hineinzugeben,
immer da ist, ja und und man genau schaut, mit wem man äh zusammenarbeitet und dass äh die Kontrolle am Ende in den USA,
und äh diese Vorbehalte begab's dann in Europa eben nicht mehr. Das ähm da war die ESA unabhängig von äh nationaler Gängelung, äh weil es sozusagen die Supra äh Regierung in Europa ja nicht gab und und und,
autonomie sozusagen in in Paris äh hier ähm.
Lag und immer noch liegt und das ist der große Vorteil. Was wir heute äh ja sehen, ist dann eher, dass es eine Art von Konkurrenz gibt jetzt äh.
In den letzten Jahren darüber, wer wirklich das Sagen hat, ob's die Europäische Kommission.
Oder ob es die ESA ist und hier sehen wir äh sozusagen es könnte auch ja eine Konstellation geben, wo die ESA äh dann doch sozusagen der Rationalität der Europäischen Kommission äh zu,
gehochen hat und der und die Europäische Kommission versucht diesen sozusagen Zugriff auf die Esar schon seit einigen Jahren. Die ESA widersteht ihm und und hätte
dagegen, aber eine solche, sozusagen neue Konfigurierung der Raumfahrt in Europa ist viel diskutiert worden
das das da ist sozusagen äh natürlich auch ein Lockmittel da, ja, dass man jetzt mal unabhängig wird von diesem Esel Ministerrat, wo man immer wieder Kompromisse schließen muss, was die Finanzierung betrifft und wenn man das sozusagen jetzt von der von der Europäischen Kommission bekommt aus dem.
Haushalt ähm aus dem riesigen Haushalt der äh Forschungshaushalt der Kommission, ja? Äh der der der jetzt im im im neuen Rahmenprogramm ähm Horizont, was ist der? Achtzig Milliarden äh et cetera. Das ist natürlich sozusagen die
das Lockmittel des großen Geldes, aber bisher hat die ESA dem widerstanden. Ich glaube aus guten Gründen widerstanden sich sozusagen zurück äh.
Zurück zu integrieren in in die große europäische politische Erzählung.
Und in gewisser Hinsicht ist ja auch die ESA gar nicht mal nur europäisch. Ich meine, er hat das europäische im äh im Namen, aber äh.
Abgesehen von den Kooperationen gibt's ja auch noch die assoziierten Mitglieder. Das ist ja unter anderem auch Kanada.
Man hat so den Eindruck, dass äh die ESA in gewisser Hinsicht auch zu so einer Isar werden könnte, zu so einer internationalen Space äh Sociation. Ähm.
Trotzdem ist natürlich dieser EU-Move ganz interessant, also es gibt ja jetzt vor allem zwei große Initiativen, die von der EU angestoßen wurden. Auf der einen Seite Galileo, das ist ein Navigationssystem.
Was von der EU finanziert wird und
auch das äh Programm der Erdbeobachtung. Das ist ja auch sehr umfangreiche, langfristige strategisch auch äh sicherlich äh wichtige Sachen. Ist der Einfluss der EU dann an der Stelle.
Eher hilfreich oder eher problematisch oder eher beides.
Ja
Würde doch sagen wie immer beides. Äh insofern also natürlich auch zusätzliche Möglichkeiten eröffnet. Zusätzliches Geld und ich glaube die noch mal die Stärke Europas liegt in dieser,
Geografie. Das ist eine ähm dass es eine Esar gibt, aber daneben unterschiedliche Formen der Kooperation, bilaterale Projekte, multilaterale Projekte. Wir haben jetzt äh vor.
Vorher gesprochen von einem Europa, der einem nordischen Europa der Raumfahrt äh Kooperation. Man steht nicht nur die europäische Raumfahrt.
Nur auf einem Bein, sondern sie hat multilaterale Möglichkeit, ein multivalente.
Und äh und dazu kommt jetzt kommen die Initiativen der Europäischen Kommission. Sie haben zwei da zwei wichtigsten genannt und ich glaube, das ist die Stärke, das ist das ist dieses multiple Europa der Raumfahrt äh zusammenarbeiten.
Und nicht.
Nur den einen großen Player, der ist wichtig und der ist äh äh historisch äh dominant. Äh die ESA und äh ganz toll aufgestellt äh und doch gibt es äh komplementäre Programme. Das ist die Stärke Europas.
Sind wir so ein bisschen schon fast in der Gegenwart angekommen. Das ist ja jetzt
gar nicht ihr äh Expertisen äh fällt, aber vielleicht auch mal so aus dieser ganzen äh Erfahrung der Geschichte heraus und wie sich das jetzt abgezeichnet hat.
Was sind so die Chancen der europäischen Raumfahrt jetzt auch weiterhin gut mitzuhalten. Wir haben jetzt gesehen, dass die.
Ganze technologische Entwicklung sich mittlerweile so konsolidiert hat, dass eben auch Firmen.
Natürlich SpaceX zu nennen. Wir werden aber auch noch
weitere Container glaube ich äh sehen in den nächsten Jahren, die noch stärker werden können, vielleicht auch in Europa.
Gehe halt einfach diese ganze Abhängigkeit von Launching ähm ganz neu definiert, die hohe Zahl an Starts, die hohe Zuverlässigkeit, die Wiederverwendbarkeit von äh Raketen spielt ja eine große Rolle und jetzt steht Europa
den Launscher Teil betrifft, der dann doch auch auf einmal wieder ein bisschen schlechter da. Ja, man hat Probleme mit der Ariane sechs, die Ariane sechs ist halt auch so ein
politischer Kompromiss gewesen, der so ja die einen wollten das und die anderen wollten das und dann kam man irgendwie da äh gerade auf dieser wichtigen Frankreich-Deutschlandachse nicht so richtig, da
zu überein, zu sagen, lass doch mal die Wissenschaft machen, sondern es wurde eben nicht einfach die Wissenschaft äh äh,
freigelassen und konnte tun, was sie für richtig gehalten hätte, was vielleicht auf ein anderes Design hinausgelaufen wäre und jetzt
vor der Situation, dass man mit der Ariane sechs quasi eine neue Generation hat, die eigentlich schon veraltet wirkt in dem Moment, wo sie das erste Mal starten.
So und man hat auch jetzt grad nicht so den Eindruck, dass man so mit diesem Speed, den die Amerikaner äh da jetzt an den Tag legen, irgendwie nennenswert noch mithalten könnte. Das ist ja schon in gewisser Hinsicht auch eine Bedrohung dieser Eigenständigkeit.
Das alles richtig was sie sagen große Raumfahrt,
äh Kramme und Projekte wie die Ariane sechs sind am Ende eben doch von Ressourcen nach von dem Zufluss von Ressourcen oder die Ressourcen kommen, äh nicht aus der Wirtschaft, die kommen aus der Politik. Die Raumfahrt ist eine
und Trieben und staatsnah nach wie vor staatsnahe Technologie, auch wenn die Kommerzialisierung der Raumfahrt jetzt ansteht und viel darüber geredet wird und äh wir erleben's ja in diesen Tagen.
Wochen und Monaten, äh wo es sozusagen jetzt amerikanische privatwirtschaftliche Unternehmen äh der der NASA-Konkurrenz machen und ihr das äh jedenfalls in der öffentlichen Resonanz äh den den Rang ablaufen, also die Kommerzialisierung der Raumfahrt
ist ja ein ähm ein ein historischer Prozess, ein Prozess, der
seit Jahren diskutiert wird, ja Jahrzehnten diskutiert wird, ich erinnere mich an die an die neunziger Jahre, da hat man schon viel über Kommerzialisierung der Raumfahrt geredet und jetzt greift sie tatsächlich äh einmal und wir sehen's ja auf vielen Ebenen, nicht nur auf der
auf der viel zitierten Ebene der Teflon-Pfanne et cetera, dass wir sozusagen Spin-Off
aus der Raumfahrt im Alltag erleben, sondern eben auch sozusagen Missionen äh äh Weltraummissionen sozusagen plötzlich zugänglich werden, wenn auch.
Nur für ein paar Superreiche äh Personen auf dieser Welt äh.
Tourismus.
Der Tourismus, der dann auch so auch unter ökologischen Aspekten ziemlich fragwürdig ist. Aber vielleicht führt uns genau dieses Stichwort
dann doch auch wiederum zu einer Stärke und zu einem profilgebenden Faktor Europas
Glaube in der Umweltforschung, in das Satelliten, den Satellitenmission, die äh äh das.
Bewältigen äh was wir heute insbesondere brauchen, den Klimawandel zu bekämpfen et cetera, ist Europa steht Europa gut da und die sind die sind.
Gleisigkeit, die ähm.
Europa seit den 70er Jahren, seit der sozusagen ESA-Gründung gefahren ist, sowohl Trägerraketen zu konstruieren als auch in der in den in den Raum, in dem Weltraummissionen äh stark zu sein. Sei es jetzt für die äh
kosmologischen äh also für die Kosmosforschung wichtigen Planet äh Planetenforschung oder und et cetera wichtigen ähm.
Mission als auch die Erdbeobachtungsmission ähm äh zu betreiben und und hier ein Profil zu entwickeln
mit äh mit der mit der Integration von äh außen ohne Witze, Forschung in den Max-Planck-Einrichtungen, äh Institut der Max-Planck-Planck-Gesellschaft et cetera. Das ist auch eine starke Europas oder das ist vielleicht,
Europas jenseits der Kommerzialisierung geblieben und ich denke, äh in in der jetzigen
Konstellation ja sozusagen Transformationskonstellation in der man uns hinten nämlich uns sozusagen im Zeitalter des Anthropozäns mit Planetaren Perspektiven bewegen zu müssen hin zu äh der
der der Lösung der großen,
Planetaren, Probleme, Klimawandel, et cetera, Biodiversitätsmonitoring ähm ist die ESA gut aufgestellt und ist Europa gut aufgestellt.
Keinen besseren Moment äh hier das Gespräch zu beenden, Herr Tischler. Vielen, vielen, vielen Dank für die,
ähm zur Geschichte der europäischen äh Raumfahrt und ich kann allen empfehlen, dass wenn jetzt hier im Mai die Ausstellung auch wieder äh eröffnet ist, dann äh auch mal hier ins deutsche Museum.
Rein zu äh schauen. Ich werde die Gelegenheit sicherlich äh wahrnehmen, wenn sie sich dann äh neu bietet. Ja, um dann äh auch hier nochmal einen anderen Blick äh zu bekommen.
Darauf freuen wir uns.
Ja. Vielen vielen Dank und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören bei äh Raumzeit.